Salut, moi c'est Guillaume Hachez. Bienvenue dans Septante Minutes Avec. Pour ce onzième épisode, je me suis rendu au Parlement fédéral belge pour rencontrer Gilles Vanden Burre, député à la Chambre des représentants pour le parti Ecolo.
C'est le troisième et dernier volet d'une série d'épisodes consacrés à la politique belge. On l'avait dit avec Alain Gerlache, il y a deux semaines, le parti Ecolo a complètement le vent en poupe.
Et aux prochaines élections, le groupe Ecolo-Groen risque très fort de devenir le premier à l'échelle nationale.
On a entre autres parlé du bilan d'Ecolo à l'issue des élections communales en octobre dernier, de l'évolution du parti en termes de positionnement, des réformes institutionnelles qu'ils veulent défendre,
mais aussi, comme souvent dans ce podcast, de révolution numérique, de culture d'entreprise et évidemment d'écologie.
Voilà, je m'excuse d'avance aux auditeurs qui nous écoutent depuis l'étranger. Il y a beaucoup de politique belge dans cet épisode, mais voilà, je vous promets que c'est le dernier avant un bon bout de temps.
Voilà, c'est parti. Et bonjour à tous. Je suis aujourd'hui au Parlement fédéral belge avec mon invité Gilles Vanden Burre, député fédéral Ecolo.
Il suit principalement des dossiers comme l'économie, l'entrepreneuriat, les PME, les infrastructures publiques ainsi que tout ce qui touche à l'intérieur et à la justice.
Gilles Vanden Burre, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Question légère pour commencer. Votre carrière politique a commencé il n'y a pas si longtemps. Auparavant, vous avez travaillé pour la banque CBC ou pour le groupe Umicore.
C'est assez rare que pour être souligné dans le parcours d'un politicien. Est-ce que vous estimez que la politique, c'est désormais sans aucun doute, pour les trente prochaines années, votre métier, votre carrière ?
Ou bien est-ce que, au contraire, vous vous laissez la liberté de peut-être retourner un jour travailler dans le privé ?
Non, je pense pas que la politique soit une carrière en soi. Donc moi, je ne me souhaite pas, en fait, d'être encore à faire,
je dirais pas de la politique, mais en tout cas être député fédéral dans trente ans, ce n'est pas du tout mon objectif.
J'espère vraiment avoir encore plusieurs vies professionnelles, que ce soit dans le privé, dans le public, parce que je pense aussi qu'il y a plusieurs manières de faire de la politique, hein, pas uniquement dans les parlements.
Et donc oui, moi, je pense que c'est assez sain. Je trouve que c'est même
une certaine plus-value, en fait, de pouvoir arriver de son domaine d'expertise, et de pouvoir amener quelque chose en politique par rapport à cela, d'une expérience de terrain.
Donc moi, c'est effectivement dans le
dans le monde de l'entreprise où j'ai travaillé une douzaine d'années. Et juste avant de devenir député, j'étais moi-même directeur d'un incubateur d'entreprises, hein, lié à l'environnement et au développement durable, GreenBizz.
Et donc oui, je pense que c'est une vraie, c'est vraiment intéressant de pouvoir avoir plusieurs parcours et je me souhaite, durant encore les vingt-cinq, vingt-sept ans qu'il me reste normalement, hein, si la santé suit,
de carrière professionnelle,
j'espère pouvoir encore avoir plusieurs vies professionnelles.
Oui, je me le souhaite et je pense que c'est très sain.
Oui. Vous le disiez, vous avez travaillé, donc vous avez dirigé cet incubateur GreenBizz. Donc on voit les connexions avec le monde de l'entrepreneuriat, et ainsi de suite.
Qu'est-ce qui vous a amené à passer, voilà, en politique ?
En fait, j'ai toujours été intéressé par la politique, par la chose publique, depuis que, je dirais, je suis en âge de pouvoir le suivre et le comprendre, déjà quand j'étais étudiant ou plus jeune.
Donc ce n'est pas nouveau mon intérêt pour la politique. Et c'est vrai que j'ai par ailleurs été actif dans différents mouvements associatifs, dans différentes ASBL.
Avant de rejoindre, je dirais, plus officiellement et de prendre une carte de parti, hein, de rejoindre un parti, Ecolo en l'occurrence, c'était en 2010, donc il y a neuf ans maintenant.
Donc j'avais trente-et-un ans. Donc voilà, je veux dire, c'était pas... J'ai préféré faire, m'engager avant, en dehors de parti politique.
Mais c'est vrai que ce qui m'a amené à Ecolo était clairement en lien avec, évidemment, des convictions fortes que j'avais.
Premièrement, tout ce qui était gouvernance. Moi, je suis très attaché à la gouvernance dans le sens gestion de l'État.
Et je pense vraiment que les gestionnaires publics doivent être irréprochables. Faire de la politique autrement, et c'est encore plus, je dirais, d'actualité aujourd'hui.
Donc c'est quelque chose qui me parle beaucoup. Aussi, tout ce qui a trait aussi au rapprochement entre les différentes communautés du pays, flamands, francophones, bruxellois, germanophones.
Ici, on est un groupe commun à la Chambre
avec Groen. Pour moi, c'est quelque chose qui est très important parce que je pense que les problèmes climatiques, que les problèmes sociaux, que les problèmes économiques ne s'arrêtent pas à la frontière linguistique.
Et donc je pense vraiment que, et ni même aux frontières nationales, hein, puisque je suis très pro, très européen, évidemment aussi.
Et donc ça, c'est quelque chose, voilà, que chez Ecolo et donc chez Groen, j'ai pu retrouver. Et évidemment, les problèmes liés
aux ressources, en fait, de la planète, puisque moi, c'est vraiment ça qui m'a amené, via mon travail
dans le monde de l'entreprise, je me suis rendu compte,
qu'effectivement, on ne pourrait pas, on ne peut pas continuer comme on le fait aujourd'hui, c'est-à-dire profiter de matières premières, produire, jeter.
Hein, c'est l'économie linéaire, ce cycle, je pense. En plus, moi, j'ai travaillé, comme vous l'avez dit, chez Umicore, qui est un recycleur.
Enfin, un de ses grands pôles d'activité, c'est recycler des métaux. Moi, j'ai travaillé dans cette division-là, au sein d'Umicore, aux quatre coins du monde, surtout en Amérique du Sud.
Et je me suis rendu compte qu'effectivement, dans tous ces pays où massivement, on fait appel au sous-sol pour satisfaire nos besoins de production, on peut pas continuer de la sorte.
Sinon, il nous faudrait une dizaine de planètes équivalentes à la planète Terre, ce qui est impensable pour les générations futures.
Et donc voilà, c'est vraiment ça qui m'a permis aussi d'arriver vers l'écologie politique et, je dirais, une dimension vraiment liée aux ressources de la planète.
C'est vraiment ça, en tout cas, moi, par rapport à ce que, je dirais, ce volet économique de l'écologie qui m'a amené chez Ecolo.
Oui, vous avez évoqué votre pendant néerlandophone, Groen. On voit une cohésion très importante entre les deux partis.
Vous formez un seul groupe au sein du Parlement, ce qui n'est pas le cas, par exemple, des libéraux, des socialistes, des humanistes.
Comment est-ce que vous expliquez que la cohésion soit aussi forte ? Et pourquoi, à ce moment-là, ne pas faire un seul parti à l'échelle nationale ?
Alors la cohésion, elle est effectivement très forte parce que, je dirais, dans l'ADN écologiste, nous sommes nés après, enfin quand la Belgique était
déjà dans un processus de plus une Belgique unitaire, de la Belgique de papa, hein.
Ecolo et Groen sont nés dans les années 80.
Ouais, ouais.
Donc après les premières, en tout cas, velléités de réforme de l'État. Et donc je pense qu'on est quelque part le fruit aussi de cette fédéralisation de la Belgique.
Donc, on est nés en Flandre et en Belgique francophone. Agalev, à l'époque, l'ancêtre de Groen en Flandre, Ecolo du côté francophone.
Et en fait, on s'est rendu compte qu'effectivement, sur une série de sujets,
ça n'a aucun sens, en fait, d'être divisé sur une fracture communautaire en fonction de sa langue, en fonction de sa culture, même s'il y a des différences.
Mais donc notre credo fédéraliste Ecolo et Groen, c'est de dire : On est plus forts ensemble, même si on a évidemment des différences.
C'est l'unité dans la diversité. Et moi, c'est quelque chose qui me parle très fort. Donc, ça ne veut pas dire qu'il faut tout, qu'il faut revenir à la Belgique de papa.
Loin de là, loin de là. On est pour un État fédéral, mais un État fédéral, ça veut aussi dire être conscient de ses forces ensemble.
Et c'est pour ça qu'on estime qu'au niveau fédéral, au Parlement belge, on est plus forts ensemble, Ecolo et Groen. Et je pense que ça a beaucoup de sens.
Je pense que beaucoup de partis nous regardent avec un certain étonnement, mais parfois une certaine
envie, parce qu'on peut transcender énormément de clivages communautaires et Dieu sait s'il y en a en Belgique, sur des sujets parfois sensibles où quelque part,
les autres partis nous regardent en se disant : Si le groupe commun Ecolo-Groen arrive à avoir une position commune sur tel ou tel sujet, eh bien, eux-mêmes sortent déjà du communautaire par le haut, finalement.
Et donc, pour moi, c'est vraiment fondamental et c'est dans l'ADN des écologistes, que ce soit aussi au niveau européen, que ce soit à d'autres niveaux, cette unité dans la diversité.
Pourquoi pas devenir un seul parti ? Je dirais, on a déjà un bureau politique commun, Ecolo et Groen. Donc, on va effectivement plus loin que le groupe commun.
On va maintenant, en vue de 2019, avoir une plateforme programmatique commune, en tout cas pour les élections fédérales.
Donc, on va loin. Pourquoi pas un seul parti ? Parce qu'effectivement, il y a encore des différences entre,
je dirais, Flamands, Francophones, qu'elles soient médiatiques, qu'elles soient culturelles, les mondes médiatiques en particulier, puisque la politique se fait aussi à travers les médias et c'est normal.
Évidemment, il y a des différences, des différences d'expression, des débats parfois qui sont différents.
Et donc, moi, ça ne me gêne pas qu'il y ait encore des partis, évidemment, différents, mais on va extrêmement loin dans la collaboration, la cocréation, la corédaction de programmes et de propositions.
Étant donné ce constat, est-ce que vous seriez favorable à une circonscription fédérale ?
Oui, tout à fait. Donc, on porte vraiment ce sujet. On estime que pour les sujets fédéraux, il faudrait qu'on, en tant que francophones
ou Wallons plutôt, hein, on puisse se présenter en Flandre et vice versa et se présenter dans l'ensemble du pays.
Le Premier ministre, aujourd'hui francophone, il n'y a pas, pour moi, de raison qu'il ne puisse pas se présenter aux électeurs flamands.
Aujourd'hui, ce n'est pas possible. Et donc c'est vrai que c'est une incohérence dans notre système et nous le regrettons.
Et donc nous sommes tout à fait pour une circonscription fédérale.
Et dans un scénario avec une circonscription fédérale, on pourrait alors voter pour Ecolo ou Groen au nord et Ecolo ou Groen au sud ?
Ou bien est-ce qu'on partirait plus à ce moment-là sur une fusion ?
Oui, on irait sur une liste commune, alors, je pense. On n'est pas dans le scénario, mais à Bruxelles, par exemple, à la Chambre.
Donc, aux Communales, on fait des listes communes systématiquement et à la Chambre, nous allons faire une liste commune Ecolo-Groen.
Donc, on l'a déjà fait en 2014, on le refait. L'accord est assez récent. Pour 2019, on va faire une liste commune.
Au cas par cas selon les, voilà, selon les programmes.
Mais on le ferait bien à la Régionale bruxelloise, au niveau de la Région bruxelloise, on le ferait aussi, mais le problème, c'est qu'on ne peut pas aujourd'hui, puisque vous devez, au moment de voter,
en tant que citoyen bruxellois, vous devez choisir d'abord votre langue et alors ensuite, vous avez les partis qui apparaissent.
Oui, c'est ça.
Et donc vous ne pouvez pas mettre deux fois Ecolo-Groen parce qu'on devrait changer le nom du parti. Enfin, il y a une complexité qui est très peu, voilà, qui est très peu lisible pour
nos concitoyens, mais qui fait que ce n'est pas possible.
Mais par contre, au niveau fédéral, on va le faire. Je pense qu'on sera les seuls. Donc, de nouveau, si demain, il y a une circonscription fédérale, les écologistes seront sous le label Ecolo-Groen.
On évoquera plus tard, voilà, toutes les réformes des institutions qui sont dans votre programme. Un petit mot d'abord sur la crise que nous venons de traverser.
Est-ce qu'à vos yeux, l'image du Premier ministre Charles Michel est plutôt ternie à l'issue de cette crise gouvernementale ou au contraire, est-ce qu'il a plutôt bien géré ?
Disons, compte tenu des cartes qu'il avait en main, de ce que la NVA a décidé de faire, est-ce que suite à cet incident-là, vous estimez qu'il s'est bien débrouillé ou est-ce que vous avez des choses à redire ?
Disons que moi, ce qui me dérange le plus dans le comportement de Charles Michel,
Premier ministre donc, c'est plutôt les quatre années et demi qu'on vient de vivre où moi, j'ai eu l'impression, enfin plus qu'une impression, j'ai vraiment ressenti qu'il était
trop souvent l'otage de la NVA, dans toute une série de sujets.
On l'a vu sur la politique liée à l'asile et la migration de Theo Francken, où Theo Francken tenait des propos complètement terribles par rapport aux étrangers, par rapport
à la manière de ne pas accueillir, en fait, les gens, les réfugiés qui ont traversé souvent
des continents ou des demi-continents pour arriver chez nous, qui, n'oublions pas, a quand même dit qu'il fallait nettoyer le parc Maximilien.
Enfin, c'est des phrases quand même, c'est au-delà d'un tweet, hein, ce que porte cette symbolique de vocabulaire de Theo Francken.
Et pour moi, c'est vraiment dans le domaine de l'indignation vraiment totale et la condamnation la plus ferme par rapport à ce type de propos.
Et donc moi, ce que je regrette, c'est qu'à un moment donné, le Premier ministre, qui est le Premier ministre de nouveau, voilà, de tous les Belges, même si moi-même,
je m'oppose à sa politique, mais il faut reconnaître que c'est le Premier ministre de tous les Belges,
c'est— voilà, moi, je regrette vraiment qu'il ne se soit pas davantage opposé à ce type-là de politique et d'expression publique de certains de ses ministres, et en particulier NVA.
Oui, vous faites là plutôt le bilan des quatre dernières années de son gouvernement. Mais disons que, voilà, spécifiquement sur le mois de décembre, sur ce qui s'est passé entre
raffermissement de la position de la NVA vis-à-vis du pacte de Marrakech et la démission de Charles Michel, est-ce que vous estimez qu'il a bien géré ces quatre semaines-là ?
Ou je ne sais plus combien de semaines. Mais compte tenu, voilà, des cartes qu'il avait en main.
Je voulais mettre en contexte par rapport aux—
Bien sûr
... quatre dernières années parce que évidemment,
cela explique aussi pour moi qu'à un moment donné, je pense que c'était une couleuvre de plus qu'il n'a pas souhaité avaler, Charles Michel, le pacte des migrations, le pacte de Marrakech,
parce que aussi les élections communales sont passées par là.
Soyons clairs, je pense qu'aussi bien la NVA en Flandre a perdu des plumes, que le MR à Bruxelles et en Wallonie a perdu des plumes.
Et le MR s'est rendu compte qu'il ne pouvait plus continuer à avaler toutes les couleuvres que lui faisait avaler la NVA.
Et donc là, ils ont dit : C'est celle-là, on ne va pas l'avaler. Et je m'en réjouis. Je m'en réjouis puisque c'est même Ecolo et Groen qui ont déposé le texte de résolution parlementaire
demandant au gouvernement de voter en faveur du Pacte des migrations à l'ONU.
Donc, je me réjouis que mon pays, hein, et donc mon Premier ministre, ait voté, officiellement, en tout cas approuvé officiellement ce pacte.
Donc, à ce niveau-là, je suis content qu'il y ait effectivement eu cette prise de position ferme du Premier ministre par rapport au refus de la NVA.
Maintenant, je ne me fais pas non plus d'illusion. C'est-à-dire que c'est un calcul essentiellement politicien, je dirais, ou politique qui, voilà—
Entre deux élections
...et voilà, est la conséquence des résultats des élections communales. Donc, je ne me fais pas d'illusion par rapport à un changement de politique du gouvernement Michel.
Par contre, oui, je salue le fait que notre pays ait tenu son rang et son honneur d'approuver le pacte de Marrakech.
Il y a eu le temps de quelques semaines avant, voilà, qu'il finisse par omettre sa décision, une ambition de travailler avec un gouvernement minoritaire, en négociant avec chaque groupe individuellement au sein de la chambre.
Ecolo avait évidemment de sérieux problèmes avec le mandat de la COP vingt-quatre. Il y a eu une motion, il me semble, de recommandation, je crois que c'est le terme, le matin même de la démission de Charles Michel.
Et l'après-midi, Ecolo, quelques heures après cette motion de recommandation, Ecolo cosignait une motion de méfiance. Est-ce qu'il n'y a pas une légère contradiction quand on signe une motion de recommandation et de méfiance le même jour ?
Mais disons que notre objectif, c'était de dire au Premier ministre, mais comme on le fait en fait depuis quatre ans, parce que nous, Ecolo-Groen, on a un principe très clair, c'est critiquer, mais proposer.
C'est-à-dire que si on n'est pas d'accord, on critique. Oui, ça, c'est normal, c'est la démocratie. Mais on va systématiquement proposer.
Critiquer pour critiquer, c'est vraiment pas notre marque de fabrique. Et donc c'était le même esprit ici : passer, demander effectivement des recommandations.
On a recommandé une série de choses, en particulier les politiques climatiques. Nous avons par ailleurs obtenu un vote positif sur une proposition de résolution.
On demande à la Belgique d'aller plus loin dans les ambitions climatiques, à l'horizon deux mille trente, sur une diminution de cinquante-cinq pour cent des gaz à effet de serre, alors que ce n'était pas le cas.
Donc, on a réussi à engranger positivement pour le climat des mesures, en tout cas une ambition forte. Et par contre, faire que des recommandations, on n'était pas non plus dans une naïveté.
Donc quand certains autres partis, donc c'était une motion de défiance,
cosignée, 'fin, qui était déposée par les socialistes, nous l'avons cosignée parce que nous estimons qu'effectivement, à un moment donné, on ne peut pas juste donner un chèque en blanc au Premier ministre.
Signer une motion de méfiance, ça veut dire qu'il a quarante-huit heures pour venir s'expliquer devant le gouvernement.
On estimait qu'il devait faire la clarté parce qu'on entendait à la fois qu'il draguait la NVA qui venait d'arriver dans l'opposition pour avoir un budget voté.
Et en même temps, il nous disait : J'entends les septante mille personnes qui ont marché pour le climat à Bruxelles.
J'entends qu'il faut aller plus loin. J'entends aussi la détresse sociale, hein, via le mouvement des gilets jaunes. Donc, il a eu un discours aussi,
je reconnais, qui pour moi, a été une différence par rapport aux quatre ans et demi qu'il a menés.
Oui, vraiment. Mais en même temps, il disait à la NVA : Attendez, moi, j'aime bien travailler avec vous. Et donc ça, c'est pas possible
de faire, je dirais, un shopping électoral constant et de dire le matin, je vais essayer de faire adopter un texte grâce aux voix de la NVA et l'après-midi, je vais essayer d'adopter un texte grâce aux voix d'Ecolo-Groen.
Ça, c'est complet... ça, ça n'a... Il n'y a pas de cohérence. Et donc ça, nous, on ne pouvait pas laisser se... Il fallait de la clarté.
Donc c'est ce que nous avons demandé. Et finalement, effectivement, Charles Michel a choisi d'aller
poser sa démission. Ce qui n'empêche pas aujourd'hui, janvier deux mille dix-neuf, le Parlement est en pleine possession de ses moyens et donc nous continuons à avoir des débats, à poser des exigences sur la table.
La vie politique ne s'arrête pas. Effectivement, le gouvernement est en affaires courantes, c'est clair, mais voilà, en mai prochain, on aura des élections quoi qu'il arrive.
Et donc je pense que des choses sont encore possibles. Mais de nouveau, le matin, dire : On va voter des textes avec la NVA et l'après-midi avec Ecolo-Groen, ça, c'est un jeu dans lequel, effectivement, on ne voulait pas s'inscrire.
Très bien. Vous avez évoqué les élections communales d'octobre dernier qui sont, voilà, un événement qui a vraiment chamboulé le paysage politique belge.
Beaucoup ont été surpris lors du scrutin par la forte montée d'Ecolo-Groen.
Au lendemain de ce scrutin, une analyse qui revenait souvent dans la presse, c'était que la pillarisation de la Belgique commençait à sérieusement s'effriter et qu'aujourd'hui, en particulier chez les jeunes,
on fonctionne beaucoup moins sur ce modèle-là de,
libéral ou socialiste de père en fils, je vote comme mes parents et ainsi de suite.
Est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec cette analyse ? Est-ce que vous la partagez ?
Oui, je partage cette analyse de dire, je pense qu'aujourd'hui, ce qui est important, c'est surtout de voir quelles sont les valeurs et les enjeux de chaque parti politique, chaque formation politique.
Je pense qu'effectivement, le vote, selon les piliers traditionnels de la Belgique, socialistes, catholiques, libéraux, effectivement, moi, je les identifie pas comme des marqueurs, en tout cas primordiaux.
Forcément, puisque vous, vous êtes chez Ecolo, jeune parti. Mais voilà, le constat, c'est vraiment de voir que non seulement chez Ecolo, mais de manière générale, en particulier chez les jeunes en Belgique, cette pillarisation
n'a plus vraiment d'impact.
Vous partagez ce constat ?
C'est un constat que je partage, que je ressens aussi, puisqu'on accueille, on rencontre aussi beaucoup de jeunes, que ce soit au Parlement ou en dehors.
Et effectivement, je pense que leurs préoccupations sont effectivement, voilà, sont pas vraiment liées à des piliers,
en tout cas les piliers traditionnels de la Belgique, mais effectivement plutôt à des inquiétudes, à des sujets qui les mobilisent.
Et c'est vrai que très régulièrement, on se rend bien compte que l'urgence climatique, par exemple,
mobilise beaucoup la jeune génération. Je m'en réjouis, même, même si j'aimerais finalement qu'il y ait pas cette urgence climatique et qu'on ait effectivement un environnement qui soit bien davantage respecté.
Mais donc, que cette génération-là se dise : Si on ne fait rien dans les dix, quinze ans à venir, on va vraiment dans le mur, et qu'on en prenne conscience et qu'on prenne des actes.
Moi, ça, effectivement, ça me, oui, ça me rend positif, effectivement, parce que je pense qu'il est temps de passer aux actes forts.
Et effectivement, on sent que par rapport à cette jeune génération, il y a une vraie envie de bouger les choses. Il se fait que voilà, en termes d'urgence climatique,
évidemment, chez Ecolo, on est mobilisé sur ce sujet depuis très longtemps.
Et donc, je pense que c'est ce qui explique en partie notre score, très, enfin le résultat très positif du quatorze octobre dernier, à Bruxelles, en Wallonie.
Et je pense aussi que voilà, il y a clairement un positionnement sur ces sujets-là qui nous a été favorable et aussi une constance qui nous est reconnue.
Je veux dire, on n'a pas changé de fusil d'épaule avec le contexte ou avec, je dirais, l'humeur du moment.
Ce changement-là, voilà cet effritement de la polarisation du paysage belge, les trois partis traditionnels qu'on évoquait, donc les libéraux, catholiques et socialistes, ne semblent pas vraiment l'avoir vu venir.
Ils ont peut-être un peu été pris de court. Vous avez, pour ainsi dire, piqué beaucoup d'électeurs chez chacun de ces trois partis.
Ça signifie que le profil sociologique des électeurs a changé. Voilà, donc comme on le disait, on ne vote plus parce que,
parce que papa était socialiste ou que sais-je, mais on vote, voilà, selon des problématiques qui nous sont propres et donc souvent chez les jeunes, le mouvement écologique.
Quel impact est-ce que ça a pour un parti comme Ecolo d'avoir au sein de sa base électorale une plus grande pluralité, une plus grande diversité de profils autant sociologiques qu'idéologiques ?
Puisqu'on a des gens, voilà, vous venez comme moi de Woluwe-Saint-Pierre, des gens qui ont peut-être des origines un peu plus marquées.
Voilà, Woluwe-Saint-Pierre, historiquement,
un maillot de droite. Pareil dans le Brabant wallon, à Uccle. Voilà, on voit des endroits où des jeunes qui appartenaient plutôt à des idées libérales vont voter Ecolo, ce qui a pris de court le mouvement réformateur pour le coup.
Voilà, quel impact est-ce que ça a sur Ecolo d'avoir une plus grande diversité, une plus grande pluralité au sein de sa base électorale ?
Je pense qu'en fait, c'est fort lié. Je pense que ça a un peu toujours été le cas. Alors, évidemment, Ecolo, dans son histoire, a vécu beaucoup d'aléas électoraux, hein.
On a déjà été jusqu'à convaincre dix-neuf pour cent de nos concitoyens, hein, en 2009, par exemple, en nonante-neuf aussi.
Après, on a eu des reflux, enfin des défaites électorales très, très cuisantes, hein, il faut appeler un chat un chat.
Mais je pense que le pluralisme au sein d'Ecolo a toujours existé. Moi, je l'ai en tout cas toujours connu.
Moi, je suis là depuis 2010, donc je ne suis pas dans les plus anciens et je ne peux pas prétendre incarner l'histoire ou l'historique du parti.
Mais moi, ce que je sens aujourd'hui, c'est que ces différents, comment dire,
origines ou en tout cas différentes sociologies, que ce soit d'électeurs, que ce soit de militants d'ailleurs, qui sont actifs au sein d'Ecolo, moi, là, je le vis très concrètement au jour le jour et on sait bien que sur différents sujets,
on a des, parfois des positionnements ou des clivages internes au sein d'Ecolo qui vont varier en fonction des sujets, parce qu'effectivement, on n'a pas,
une origine, je dirais, qu'elle soit culturelle, qu'elle soit militante, qui est la même pour chacun.
Et donc ça, c'est très fort. Par contre, je trouve que c'est aussi une richesse, parce que ça veut dire qu'on est tous,
avec les mêmes, je dirais, on a un socle commun par rapport à, voilà, se dire que l'urgence climatique aujourd'hui, c'est la priorité, l'urgence sociale également.
Et là-dessus, je pense qu'on se rejoint tous. La gouvernance, faire de la politique autrement, c'est vraiment des marqueurs très forts.
Et c'est intéressant, je trouve, de voir qu'on peut venir de,
du mouvement ouvrier chrétien, on peut venir du milieu syndical, on peut venir du monde de l'entreprise, du monde de l'enseignement et se retrouver dans les valeurs portées par Ecolo.
Moi, c'est quelque chose que je trouve comme plutôt positif. Maintenant, ça nous donne des responsabilités aussi, hein. Il faut pas, il faut pas...
Clairement, je pense que ça, c'est pas simple, hein, de gérer ça. Et c'est beaucoup d'attentes, et donc effectivement, on est attendu au tournant, mais je dirais, ça, on sait et c'est à nous de travailler et de,
et de mériter cette confiance.
Mais c'est sûr que je trouve que c'est une richesse, mais une richesse qui n'est pas toujours effectivement simple à gérer.
Oui, je suis un petit peu surpris de ce que vous disiez vis-à-vis de votre base militante, puisque donc, on a vu, par exemple, à Forest, au lendemain des communales,
Ecolo qui semblait plutôt partant pour former une majorité avec le mouvement réformateur.
Et puis, une base militante qui vraiment ne voulait pas, ne l'entendait pas comme ça. Et après avoir fortement protesté, voilà, Ecolo a finalement choisi de travailler avec le PS à Forest.
Donc, on voit plutôt cette base militante bien ancrée à gauche, non ?
Alors, je pense que la base militante, elle est d'une locale à l'autre. Moi, je suis de la locale d'Ixelles, donc ce sont les voisins, mais les Forestois.
Je pense que chaque locale, effectivement, a son historique, a sa culture. Nous, à Ixelles, on a aussi historiquement eu des prises de position au niveau local qui ont pu évoluer.
Ici, je pense que par rapport à ce qui s'est passé à Forest, je pense que c'est vraiment une histoire aussi liée à une personnalité.
Et quelle est cette personnalité ? C'est l'ancien bourgmestre socialiste qui clairement clivait énormément.
Et je sais que par exemple, au sein des militants et des collègues écolos à Forest, la grande difficulté par rapport aux socialistes, c'était pas tellement le programme,
mais c'était Marc-Jean Ghyssels, donc l'ancien bourgmestre socialiste, parce qu'il y avait une vraie incompatibilité de vue.
Il y avait une vraie divergence, de vraies, pardon, divergences sur beaucoup de choses. Et je pense, n'ayant pas été moi-même directement impliqué, mais je pense que c'est ça qui a,
cristallisé, disons, les choix qui ont été faits juste après les élections et qu'à un moment donné, au niveau du PS, on s'est aussi rendu compte que c'était plus tenable.
Et lui-même a fait un pas de côté. Donc à partir du moment, effectivement, où Marc-Jean Ghyssels dit : moi, je me retire.
Donc, je ne serai ni échevin ni candidat bourgmestre, mais ni échevin. Effectivement, au niveau de la locale d'Ecolo, ça a fort changé la donne.
On s'est dit : Tiens, la plus grande difficulté pour aller avec les socialistes au niveau de Forest, en tout cas, disparaissait.
Donc, je pense que c'est ça qui a motivé les collègues forestois à effectivement changer leur fusil d'épaule et de faire une majorité finalement avec le PS.
Et donc, c'est intéressant également parce que c'est symptomatique du fait qu'Ecolo, suite, voilà, à ce scrutin, cette vague verte
qu'on a observée en octobre, Ecolo dispose d'une position que certains qualifient de position de pivot, c'est-à-dire que le score est tellement bon qu'on peut choisir entre les libéraux, les socio-chrétiens et les socialistes.
On peut choisir. Voilà, et ça s'est fait de manière plus ou moins équilibrée à travers la Belgique, tantôt avec le MR, tantôt avec le PS.
Mais oui, mais dans le cas de Forest, vous semblez dire vraiment que... Enfin, on a vraiment constaté que la base militante était penchée fortement en faveur, voilà, plutôt des socialistes.
Oui, je pense qu'effectivement, le projet de ville, en tout cas, qui était porté à Forest, les convergences de programmes semblaient être plus fortes avec le PS.
Je pense que, comme vous le disiez, ça, c'est vraiment une question qui peut évoluer d'une commune à l'autre.
On le voit sur l'ensemble de Bruxelles, sur l'ensemble de la Wallonie. Nous allons systématiquement choisir des coalitions qui nous permettent de mettre en place notre programme de manière la plus forte.
Et donc, on verra effectivement les partenaires qui se retrouvent dans cette envie. Donc moi, effectivement, je pense que c'est la meilleure manière de faire.
Il n'y a pas de mot d'ordre spécifique pour dire : on ne va pas avec tel ou tel parti, si ce n'est l'extrême droite, évidemment.
Et donc, je pense que c'est ça qui est sain, c'est de voir là où on peut avoir le plus d'impact comme écologiste.
Au communal, ça peut fonctionner puisque comme on le disait, ça s'équilibre en Belgique francophone, tantôt avec le MR, tantôt avec le PS.
Quand on parle des régionales, quand on parle du fédéral, quand on parle des communautaires, ça ne fonctionne plus tellement, puisque là, il faut vraiment faire un choix marqué.
Est-ce que vous vous autorisez cette même liberté à choisir, selon le projet, soit avec le Mouvement réformateur, soit avec le PS, CDH, voilà, dans ces élections à plus grande échelle ?
Ou bien est-ce que là, la difficulté est plus importante compte tenu, comme on disait, d'une base électorale qui penche peut-être plus à gauche ?
Non, je pense que le raisonnement est vraiment le même. D'ailleurs, ne nous trompons pas, en Belgique, ceux qui ont le plus gouverné ensemble depuis 1830, c'est le PS avec le MR, les libéraux avec les socialistes.
Donc, je dirais, ce n'est pas toujours le-
Dans un contexte où-
La lecture gauche-droite qui prévaut dans les coalitions, historiquement.
Oui, voilà, mais dans un contexte où le Parti catholique dominait très, très, très fortement. Donc c'est un peu différent.
C'est vrai, c'est vrai. Mais donc ici, pour nous, c'est la même, c'est vraiment le même raisonnement. Je pense qu'il faudra vraiment voir dans les négociations, en fait, qui vont suivre les élections.
Et si nous sommes autour de la table, en fonction évidemment du score que vont nous donner les citoyens, voir là où on peut le faire, avec qui on peut faire le plus avancer notre programme.
Je pense que c'est vraiment ça, pour nous, l'objectif. Et moi, je ne vois pas à ce stade... Ce que je vois, c'est des difficultés en termes de politique et de valeurs.
C'est sûr que si c'est pour faire la même politique qu'en Asie, l'immigration que fait le gouvernement actuel, là, ça sera, quoi qu'il en soit, sans les écologistes.
Donc, il y a des marqueurs très forts.
Mais si on peut avancer sur des thèmes concrets en allant loin par rapport à ce que nous portons comme programme, comme mesure, je ne vois pas pourquoi nous exclurions à l'avance tel ou tel parti.
Tout est possible. C'est une réponse très intéressante puisque,
on se souvient que, voilà, il y a quinze ans, on se souvient d'une époque où Ecolo clamait haut et fort sa préférence nette pour travailler plutôt avec des coalitions marquées à gauche.
Et là, vous semblez dire qu'aujourd'hui, tout est possible. Est-ce qu'Ecolo n'a pas un petit peu changé son positionnement politique ?
Est-ce qu'Ecolo ne s'est pas un petit peu ouvert sur la droite par rapport à Ecolo d'il y a quinze ans ?
Je ne sais pas comparer par rapport à Ecolo il y a quinze ans. Ce que je peux dire, c'est qu'à l'époque,
vous faites référence, j'imagine, aux convergences des gauches, qui avaient été un accord formel, en fait, entre Ecolo et le Parti socialiste.
Il faut que je me rappelle parce que je n'y étais pas. Mais effectivement, je pense que ça a été, je dirais, on nous y reprendra plus.
C'était évidemment, ça brouillait les cartes. Je pense que comment peut-on... Enfin, pour les citoyens, il est compliqué de dire : Pourquoi encore voter Ecolo ?
Si de toute façon, ils partagent de toute façon le programme socialiste ou ils sont ensemble. Donc, je pense qu'effectivement, à ce niveau-là, on a vraiment sans doute évolué.
Et je dirais, depuis en tout cas Jean-Michel Javaux, qui disait l'équidistance. Et moi, je trouve que c'est un concept qui a du sens, c'est-à-dire, on est équidistant par rapport aux autres partis politiques.
On n'a pas de proximité spécifique avec un autre parti politique. Et moi, en tout cas, cette règle-là, elle me convient très bien.
Quand, voilà, mais sur base de ce constat, quand un parti comme Ecolo s'ouvre, voilà, un petit peu sur sa droite, comparé à Ecolo d'il y a quinze ans, quand sa base électorale se diversifie autant, comme on le disait,
et quand sa base militante reste, voilà, selon les endroits, évidemment, mais de manière générale, plutôt ancrée à gauche.
Quand on a toute cette diversité, toute cette pluralité, est-ce qu'on n'obtient pas alors un cocktail un petit peu explosif où ça va finir par... Par créer des insatisfactions.
Mais écoutez, moi, je pense que de nouveau, ce qui est important, c'est de voir qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire ensemble. Si
dans une négociation hypothétique, que ce soit au niveau régional, que ce soit au niveau fédéral,
on peut porter des mesures très fortes en termes de qualité de l'air, des mesures très fortes en termes de, moi, c'est une proposition que j'ai déposée ici et que, avec plusieurs collègues, de désinvestissement dans les énergies fossiles,
que ce soit dans les fonds de pension publics, que ce soit dans les universités, que ce soit dans tout ce qui est les organismes publics qui ont de l'argent investi en fait dans l'industrie fossile,
des énergies fossiles,
pétrolières en particulier.
Si on peut se mettre d'accord sur des objectifs ambitieux par rapport à cela. Et en même temps, effectivement, ce qui pour nous est très important, c'est en parallèle avoir une politique qui ne laisse pas les plus faibles sur le bord de la route.
Alors, c'est peut-être un slogan, mais ça veut dire
rehausser. Donc de nouveau, c'est des propositions concrètes qu'on a déposées, rehausser les allocations au niveau du seuil de pauvreté, ce qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui en Belgique.
C'est de pouvoir permettre à chaque fois, c'est une proposition que j'ai déposée, permettre à chacun
de se former et de se réorienter dans sa carrière professionnelle au lieu de punir en allant vers la dégressivité des allocations de chômage, ce qui est le choix qui a été en tout cas fait par le gouvernement avant qu'il ne tombe.
Donc, je veux dire, pour moi, si on est fidèle à ce que nous portons et si on peut le traduire dans un accord de gouvernement,
je pense que, alors, je ne dis pas que tout sera formidable et que Ecolo va vivre en interne, tous les militants vont être formidablement heureux et,
et applaudir chacun leurs parlementaires ou de leur président ou leur futur ministre,
comment dire, comme un seul homme ou comme une seule femme,
en ovation debout en assemblée générale.
Ça, je ne dis pas. La politique, c'est évidemment pas toujours unanime. Et tant mieux d'ailleurs, il y a des débats internes.
Mais je pense que le marqueur, il doit être là. Si un jour, on rentre dans des gouvernements qui vont complètement
à l'inverse de ce que nous prônons ou si on se renie nous-mêmes, je pense que forcément, on court à des grandes divisions internes, voire à des grandes déceptions.
Et c'est normal. Donc moi, j'ai plutôt envie d'être optimiste par rapport à cela, en ayant confiance en nous-mêmes.
Si des gens nous ont rejoints, je pense, je veux dire Ecolo, hein, vous faisiez une comparaison par rapport à dix, quinze ans.
Moi, en tout cas, je vais plutôt dire par rapport à ce que j'ai vécu moi-même, hein, si je fais la comparaison entre aujourd'hui et 2014, hein, donc 2014.
Mai 2014, qui quand même était une grande défaite du Parti Ecolo, hein, électoral. Bon, faut pas se voiler la face.
On a fait huit pour cent à Bruxelles et un peu, je crois, un tout petit peu plus en Wallonie. Alors, qu'est-ce qui a changé depuis lors ?
Beaucoup de choses dans la manière de travailler. En interne, on a changé évidemment aussi d'équipe de coprésidents.
Mais fondamentalement, sur ce que nous portons, je pense qu'on est restés très cohérents. On n'a pas tout d'un coup changé pour attirer des électeurs.
Ah tiens, plus du pilier socialiste ou plus du pilier libéral. Donc, je pense qu'on est restés sur les fondamentaux et les valeurs extrêmement constants depuis 2014.
Mais sur la forme, peut-être, en termes de communication-
Oui, sur la forme, sur ce qu'on fait aussi. Je veux dire, il y a des communes dans lesquelles on est au pouvoir depuis très longtemps.
Je pense à Schaerbeek, je pense à Watermael-Boitsfort aussi, où nous avions un bourgmestre, c'était le seul à Bruxelles sortant, qui a été réélu haut la main, en deux mille, enfin-
Octobre.
En octobre, oui. C'est aussi important. Ça veut dire que quand on est au pouvoir et qu'on a les manettes, en tout cas au niveau communal, les électeurs nous font encore confiance.
Moi, je pense que ça aussi, c'est important. Mais ce que je voulais dire, c'est que je ne crois pas qu'on doit nous changer maintenant avec le vent ou commencer à dire : Tiens, on va faire une analyse stratégique de qui vote pour nous,
même si on le fait, parce qu'on-
Évidemment.
On doit analyser un corps électoral avant d'aller aux élections, sinon on ne travaillerait pas correctement. Mais d'adapter son discours sur la forme, pourquoi pas, effectivement, pour,
bien faire comprendre de manière pédagogique notre programme.
Ça, moi, je n'ai aucun problème. Mais de changer sur le fond certaines choses, certaines orientations pour plaire à l'un, aux uns ou aux autres.
Justement, moi, ce qui m'a amené chez Ecolo, c'est qu'on ne fait pas ça. On n'est pas un parti qui vit d'avoir certaines clientèles en fait, et de dire : Tiens, ce secteur-là, on va systématiquement le suivre.
Et donc, s'il change d'avis, on changera d'avis. Sincèrement, moi, c'est ça aussi qui fait que je me sens bien chez Ecolo, c'est qu'on ne raisonne pas comme ça.
Et donc, je ne pense pas que sur le fond, nous ayons fait de grands virages idéologiques ou de grands virages programmatiques.
Non, mais effectivement, on se base sur certains curseurs. Et donc, je pense que la déception,
des nouveaux militants, des nouveaux membres qu'on a, des nouveaux électeurs que nous avons aussi, elle peut arriver, mais je pense que si on reste constant avec nos idées et ce que nous prônons,
on diminue ce risque.
On doit vraiment être constant avec nous-mêmes.
On évoquait tout à l'heure, voilà, la polarisation du paysage politique belge. Une des,
un des symptômes de l'immobilisme politique qu'on observe, qu'on a pu observer pendant longtemps en Belgique, c'est qu'on voit un peu toujours les mêmes têtes à la tête des partis traditionnels depuis toujours.
Ce qui n'est pas le cas chez Ecolo, parce qu'une alternance des deux coprésidents qui est assez régulière. Ecolo, donc, donne assez peu dans la personnalisation.
Est-ce que c'est un choix assumé du parti ? Est-ce que ça va à votre avantage ou est-ce que c'est plutôt une faiblesse ?
Alors oui, c'est un choix assumé. Donc, c'est-à-dire, je pense qu'on est extrêmement en faveur du renouvellement et donc de faire émerger de nouvelles personnalités.
Et moi, j'en suis, enfin, je suis personnellement convaincu que c'est une manière, en tout cas, moi, qui me plaît, de faire de la politique.
Je pense que, de nouveau, comme je le disais au début de cette interview, se dire : « Je fais de la politique durant les trente prochaines années, j'en fais ma carrière. »
Enfin, moi, c'est pas du tout
ma manière de raisonner. Je pense que c'est comme ça pour Ecolo en général. Donc ça, je pense que c'est assumé, c'est très bien de faire émerger régulièrement des nouvelles personnalités à des fortes res-,
à des forts niveaux de responsabilité, coprésident, ministre, etc.
Par contre, la personnalisation, je veux dire, elle est là en fait dans la politique en général. Je veux dire, aujourd'hui, il est difficile de...
On a encore eu le débat, pour vous dire les choses. On a eu le débat au niveau ixellois, hein, donc c'est la locale dans laquelle, de laquelle je suis membre.
Je vis à Ixelles. De se dire : « Tiens, ce serait marrant de faire des affiches électorales pour les communales, hein, d'octobre, où on mettrait que des slogans ou des questions. »
Et la semaine d'après, on enlève les questions pour mettre nos réponses. Certains collègues l'ont fait dans d'autres communes.
On trouvait ça intéressant, mais souvent,
ce qui revient alors comme commentaire, c'est : « Oui, mais attention, on sait bien que nos concitoyens votent beaucoup pour des personnes, des hommes et des femmes
qu'ils connaissent, qu'ils ont vus, hein, le fameux vu à la télé ou entendu sur podcast ou... »
Et donc, il faut en être conscient. Nous, ce n'est pas quelque chose qu'on estime spécialement être positif, hein, cette personnalisation à outrance de la politique, mais c'est une réalité.
Donc, je pense qu'on doit avoir un équilibre entre faire émerger de nouvelles personnalités, mettre l'accent sur le fond, mais aussi, effectivement, avoir des personnalités qui incarnent notre projet.
Je pense que c'est important.
Oui, oui. On vit actuellement dans une période politique assez particulière. Voilà, on est entre deux élections.
On a eu une crise politique il y a très peu de temps. Ecolo dispose, d'après les derniers sondages, d'une position assez enviable.
Je l'évoquais tout à l'heure, la position de pivot. Quand on dispose, voilà, de cette position très enviable, qu'on est finalement en mesure de choisir avec quel partenaire on veut travailler.
Est-ce que vous avez aujourd'hui une préférence, voilà, à l'horizon 2019 pour les élections fédérales, du gouvernement fédéral, une préférence nette et marquée pour un partenaire, aujourd'hui ?
Est-ce que vous en avez une ?
Groen. Donc ça, c'est très clair.
Ça, c'est, oui.
Donc oui, pour le reste, ce sera certainement avec Groen et ce sera certainement sans la N-VA.
D'accord.
Ça, c'est quelque chose— et sans l'extrême droite, mais ça, ça va de soi. On ne discute même pas avec l'extrême droite.
Ça, pour moi, ce sont les certitudes à ce stade. Pour le reste, je voulais juste réagir en disant : « Attention, on a une position effectivement, entre guillemets, confortable dans les sondages. »
Il ne faut surtout pas qu'on croie que ça soit arrivé. Il faut continuer à bosser et montrer à nos concitoyens qu'ils peuvent nous faire confiance.
Je pense que la pire erreur que nous puissions faire, c'est penser que ça y est, qu'on va pouvoir choisir à notre aise au lendemain des élections de mai prochain.
Je pense que ce ne sera pas le cas et je pense qu'il faut continuer à travailler et à montrer notre pertinence dans le débat public.
Parce que, par ailleurs, avoir une position positive pour l'instant dans les sondages, bon, c'est bien, ça fait plaisir, ça encourage, hein, on ne va pas-
Aux élections aussi.
On ne va pas se cacher. Oui, aux élections communales aussi, tout à fait. Donc c'est très positif, ça nous encourage et ça donne la niaque.
Maintenant, ça fait qu'on devient la cible privilégiée de tous les autres. Donc il faut pas-- Il faut aussi bien se dire qu'on ne va pas nous épargner.
Ça, c'est comme ça, c'est la politique. Mais donc, restons surtout concentrés sur l'objectif. Et donc le choix des partenaires, je vous dis, se posera sur base du programme.
Et je peux déjà vous dire que ce sera avec Groen et sans la N-VA.
Voilà, en conservant une certaine ambiguïté, en disant : « Ben aujourd'hui, je ne sais pas vous dire si on fera une majorité avec PS, PTB ou bien plutôt avec le MR »,
vous vous arrangez finalement pour obtenir des voix qui penchent autant plutôt à gauche que plutôt à droite.
Et il y aura finalement inévitablement des déçus. Pourquoi ? Pourquoi ne pas clarifier immédiatement aujourd'hui ? Tiens,
nous préférons aujourd'hui travailler avec peut-être le PS ou peut-être le MR ? Si c'est une décision que vous devrez faire dans quelques mois, c'est vraiment pas longtemps.
Ben parce que je pense que justement, il faut avoir le débat public, la campagne. Enfin, je pense qu'il faut savoir comment vont se positionner les uns et les autres, donc les autres partis,
sur toute une série de sujets, en particulier l'environnement, en particulier l'urgence sociale, en particulier aussi le redéploiement économique de nos régions, Bruxelles-Wallonie en particulier.
Donc voilà, je pense que c'est ça, en fait, c'est voir le débat, la campagne, le débat d'idées, les échanges. Et c'est sur cette base-là, de nouveau, qu'il faut pouvoir s'asseoir après, au lendemain des élections.
Et quand même aussi le signe de l'électeur. Alors, c'est un usage obligé. On dit toujours, il faut attendre les élections.
Mais oui, quand même, il faut quand même voir quel sera le poids que vont donner nos concitoyens à chaque parti. Et donc, c'est— mais donc, de nouveau, moi, je pense pas qu'on va faire de grands...
Et c'est pas que je ne pense pas, c'est que je suis sûr qu'on ne fera pas de grands changements de fond, en fait, d'ici mai.
Et pour dire justement : « Ah tiens, ce groupe de personnes, là, on va absolument aller faire justement du shopping électoral et on va tout d'un coup avoir des positions très différentes de ce qu'Ecolo prône depuis,
en tout cas depuis cinq ans. »
Équidistance.
Et donc équidistance par rapport aux partis, oui.
On évoquait en début d'interview la possibilité, l'intérêt d'Ecolo pour une circonscription fédérale. Est-ce que vous avez d'autres projets pour mai 2019 en termes de réforme des institutions ?
Alors, ce que nous, on aimerait bien faire, mais c'est en discussion interne, puisque, au niveau personnel, c'est vraiment quelque chose qui me tient fort à cœur,
c'est de pouvoir faire en sorte que les citoyens puissent davantage participer aux débats-
D'accord.
Dans les parlements.
Un peu plus de...
Démocratie participative, mais au-delà de... Donc aujourd'hui, moi, ce que je dis toujours aux classes qui viennent d'écoles, ou aux étudiants qui viennent ici à la Chambre,
je leur dis toujours : « Vous savez, tout est public ici. »
Et c'est très bien. C'est même le minimum. Enfin, je veux dire, ce serait pas-- c'est votre maison. Le parlement, c'est votre maison, à tous les citoyens. Mais
il n'y a rien à faire. On n'a pas énormément de personnes qui viennent assister. Alors, tous les débats ne sont pas passionnants, j'entends, mais voilà, il y a quand même des sujets qui vont forcément changer le quotidien des Be-
des Belges et des citoyens, en tout cas, qui vivent en Belgique.
Et donc, systématiquement, donc c'est ouvert, tout est ouvert. Vous pouvez venir systématiquement assister à tous les débats.
Mais moi, ce que j'aimerais, ce que nous aimerions, parce qu'on a déjà porté des propositions à ce niveau-là, c'est qu'ils puissent participer, c'est-à-dire
débattre avec nous, donc pas uniquement en audition, mais vraiment, et voter le cas échéant aussi, mais avec les députés, donc pas à la place des députés, avec les députés, ben des textes de lois, des réformes.
Et moi, j'ai par exemple proposé ici un texte avec mon collègue Christophe Calvo de Groen. On a déposé un texte qui
propose que sur certains sujets, je dirais importants de société, on puisse créer des commissions parlementaires mixtes.
Donc aujourd'hui, c'est dix-sept députés, une commission parlementaire. Nous, ce qu'on aimerait faire, c'est dix-sept députés et dix-sept citoyens tirés au sort.
Tirés au sort, oui.
Et il faut une majorité dans chaque groupe pour faire passer un texte. Ce serait quand même une petite révolution par rapport à la manière dont fonctionne le Parlement aujourd'hui.
Moi, j'aimerais bien même aller plus loin, qu'on puisse imaginer que des citoyens tirés au sort puissent devenir parlementaires ou devenir élus.
Mais ça, c'est donc un pas plus loin. Donc il va falloir voir comment mettre ça en place. C'est pas simple, mais je pense que sur le principe, aujourd'hui, on a besoin vraiment d'ouvrir les portes et les fenêtres au Parlement.
On a besoin de réoxygéner notre démocratie. Je suis pas du tout pour le table rase, il faut pas tout jeter à la poubelle.
Je pense que c'est pas du tout ça, mais c'est vraiment, voilà, il est temps aujourd'hui de-- aussi, on sent cette aspiration, hein, dans le grand public.
Moi, je pense que les gens, les jeunes en particulier, mais la plupart, l'immense majorité de nos concitoyens sont passionnés par la politique, c'est-à-dire la gestion
de la cité, hein, la gestion de la mobilité, la qualité de l'air, l'emploi, la pauvreté.
Moi, souvent, les questions qu'on me pose quand j'ai des classes ici, d'écoliers, c'est : « Monsieur, comment ça se fait qu'il y a encore des gens qui dorment dehors à Bruxelles ? »
« Comment ça se fait qu'on fait un kilomètre en deux heures si on prend sa bagnole et qu'on respire un si mauvais air ? »
Surtout pour les Bruxellois. Mais la pauvreté, ça touche les quatre coins du pays. Et donc ça, voilà, je pense qu'il y a un vrai intérêt de nos concitoyens pour ça.
Maintenant, de la politique politicienne, de savoir qui dans tel parti va faire quoi et tout, ça, je pense que par contre, il y a très peu d'intérêt.
Ce que je peux en grande partie comprendre d'ailleurs, c'est pas du tout le plus intéressant. Et donc je pense qu'amener des citoyens qui n'ont pas d'étiquette politique, qui ne sont pas spécialement, qui ne sont pas membres d'un parti
et qui viennent et qui vraiment participent pleinement, donc pas uniquement, on demande leur avis et puis, merci, et à la prochaine.
Non, on demande leur avis, ils le donnent et ils votent avec les députés. Je pense que ce changement-là, il devient inéluctable, il devient, on va devoir aller vers ça.
Est-ce que c'est maintenant dans les semaines qui viennent, dans les mois qui viennent ? Je ne sais pas, parce que ça, il faut quand même changer la Constitution.
Donc c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas simple en Belgique, mais je pense vraiment qu'il faut aller vers ça. Et j'espère vraiment pouvoir avoir, à ce niveau-là, un programme très ambitieux au niveau d'Ecolo pour 2019.
Donc toujours sur la question des institutions à réformer, est-ce que vous seriez par exemple en faveur de refédéraliser certaines compétences, comme notamment tout ce qui touche à l'énergie, à l'écologie ?
Alors oui, nous sommes assez favorables à refédéraliser certaines compétences. Je pense que de manière générale d'ailleurs, on est favorable à la réflexion autour des compétences en Belgique.
Pour l'instant, on a toujours été dans un seul sens, hein, vers du fédéral, on enlevait des compétences au fédéral pour les transférer aux régions, communautés.
Je pense qu'on doit avoir un jour, je dirais, l'honnêteté intellectuelle de faire l'exercice, de dire : « Voilà, où est-ce qu'une compétence est mieux gérée pour les onze millions de Belges ? »
Voilà, ça, c'est la question qu'il faut se poser, comme il faut se la poser par rapport à l'Europe aussi. Et donc effectivement, je pense qu'il y a toute une série de domaines qui probablement seraient mieux au niveau fédéral.
La sixième réforme de l'État a régionalisé une partie de la justice, par exemple. Moi, je suis certains domaines en lien avec la justice ici, j'ai fait partie de la commission attentats-
Bien sûr.
...sur les attentats du vingt-deux mars,
2016. Sincèrement, le fait que les maisons de justice soient communautaires aujourd'hui et que le reste de la, des palais de justice, du fonctionnement de la justice soit fédéral, ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens.
Vraiment, ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens. Donc ça, il faut vraiment se poser les questions. Le commerce extérieur, c'est la même chose.
Je pense que ça n'a pas énormément de sens que ce soit régionalisé. Je suis pas sûr que
les entreprises qui se situent, en tout cas au-delà des frontières européennes, ont une grande préférence ou un grand avis, savoir s'il faut s'établir à Bruxelles ou à Arlon ou Braine-l'Alleud, dans notre pays.
Donc voilà, je pense qu'il y a des choses qui seraient gérées de manière plus efficace, plus solidaire aussi, puisque si on est à
onze millions de Belges pour soutenir une politique, soins de santé, allocations familiales qui sont aujourd'hui régionalisées.
Sincèrement, je sais bien que ça a été dans le paquet de la sixième réforme de l'État et que tous les partis l'ont voté, y compris le mien, mais moi, je trouve que ça a peu de sens.
Ça a peu de sens de faire une différence entre un enfant wallon, un enfant bruxellois, un enfant flamand. Mais voilà, ça a été la pression, à un moment donné, de ce type de décision.
Mais donc oui, à certaines refédéralisations, mais pas pour refédéraliser, mais bien parce que pour l'intérêt des onze millions de Belges, c'est tout à fait pertinent.
Oui. Un sujet qui est revenu régulièrement dans ce podcast, c'est la question de ce que certains appellent la révolution numérique, le numérique à l'école en particulier.
Et un constat que j'ai fait de manière récurrente, c'est que voilà, en particulier en Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles, on a
une ministre de l'Éducation,
voilà, une ministre de l'Éducation en charge des programmes scolaires, un ministre de l'Enseignement supérieur qui est chargé de la formation des professeurs et un troisième ministre, cette fois à la Région wallonne, en charge
du matériel, de la connexion Internet, des ordinateurs, etc.
Et donc, on a ces trois ministres qui sont respectivement au CDH, PS, Mouvement réformateur, qui doivent travailler ensemble pour, voilà, cette révolution du numérique au sein de l'école.
Est-ce que vous seriez vous-même en--
favorable à une réforme où on,
voilà, les solutions peuvent varier, mais certains parlent de, par exemple, régionaliser l'enseignement, certains parlent de fusionner les deux ministères Enseignement supérieur et Enseignement obligatoire.
Est-ce qu'Ecolo a une position sur ce sujet-là ?
'Fin, nous ne sommes pas en faveur d'une régionalisation, en tout cas, en tant que telle, de l'enseignement.
Je pense par rapport à l'enseignement, ce qui est important, c'est
d'y consacrer les moyens nécessaires et de pouvoir aboutir
à une véritable transformation, en tout cas, à de véritables réformes de notre système d'enseignement qui, on le sait, en Communauté française aujourd'hui, hein, les études sont malheureusement là pour le montrer, n'est pas des,
dans les plus performants.
Et donc je pense que là, il y a tout un travail qui est fait avec le Pacte d'excellence. Nous avons évidemment des critiques, mais sur le principe de mener un projet comme le Pacte d'excellence, nous sommes,
je dirais, partie prenante.
Nous avons envie de faire avancer ce sujet-là. Nous le ferions sans doute différemment, mais bon, c'est là, c'est en place.
Il y a une très très large consultation qui a été faite, donc. Et par rapport au numérique, il y a un domaine qui-
Oui.
...qui m'intéresse tout particulièrement parce qu'il se fait qu'ici, à la Chambre, on a lancé un groupe de travail, justement, au sein d'une commission parlementaire sur la transition numérique,
sur base d'un texte Ecolo-Groen, que j'ai porté avec ma collègue Groen, Evita Willaert.
Et donc c'est fondamental de pouvoir aussi, au niveau politique, répondre à cet enjeu qui clairement, aujourd'hui- En fait, est déjà en cours depuis longtemps.
Je veux dire, on est déjà en pleine révolution numérique. Elle a commencé. On est déjà en train, en tout cas au niveau politique, de courir un petit peu après, même complètement après l'évolution en cours.
Et ici, je parle de transition numérique, je parle même pas d'intelligence artificielle, qui est encore évidemment une étape ultérieure,
mais on sait bien que là, c'est même toute l'Europe qui court un peu, même tout à fait, après d'autres pays ou continents.
Je pense aux États-Unis en particulier, à la Chine. Et donc, je pense qu'il faut que ce soit au niveau de l'enseignement.
Donc moi, je plaide clairement pour qu'il y ait, et c'est ce que je vais pousser dans le groupe de travail ici à la Chambre, même si c'est une compétence
communautaire et non fédérale, mais qu'il y ait en tout cas une réflexion pour avoir des cours liés à la compréhension du numérique dès l'âge de six ans.
Littératie numérique.
Et le cas échéant, sans écran.
Et je trouve que c'est intéressant de se dire qu'on n'a pas seulement besoin d'écran ou de la dernière tablette ou du dernier PC pour pouvoir faire des exercices en lien avec la compréhension de ce nouveau monde qui
est en train d'arriver à vitesse,
à vitesse très très rapide.
Et donc oui, concentrer les efforts, c'est fondamental. On parle aussi de mettre en place en Belgique des CEO de l'administration, au niveau tech, des CDO de l'administration.
Donc vraiment des, que notre administration puisse devenir aussi, suivre cette transition numérique comme ils le font en Estonie.
Nous, on a auditionné des responsables de l'Estonie ici au niveau du groupe de travail. Alors, est-ce qu'il faut que ce soit l'administration wallonne, l'administration bruxelloise, l'administration flamande, l'administration belge ?
Ce qu'il faut, c'est qu'il y ait des personnes en charge, qu'il y ait des moyens et qu'ils puissent faire bouger les choses.
Et on sait qu'en Belgique, tout est toujours une question de lasagne. Mais Alexander De Croo, que vous avez interrogé dans un de vos podcasts, est ministre dans une de ses nombreuses compétences de l'agenda digital.
C'est tant mieux que ça existe, mais moi, j'aimerais bien qu'il y ait un ou une ministre de l'agenda digital en Belgique, mais pas l'agenda digital et des entreprises publiques et vice-premier et ce qu'il avait, donc la compétence.
C'était une de ses nombreuses compétences. C'est déjà bien que ça existe, mais j'aurais aimé qu'il y en ait un ou une seule, tout simplement, enfin, que ce soit sa compétence unique de veiller à
centraliser les efforts, concentrer les efforts, concerter les efforts aussi entre différents niveaux de pouvoir.
Parce qu'il est vraiment temps qu'on puisse à la fois suivre cette transition numérique au niveau de
la formation des travailleurs, des travailleuses pour qu'ils puissent s'intégrer au monde économique de demain, mais qui est là, en fait, déjà.
Donc la transition économique, elle est déjà en cours. Mais aussi pouvoir réfléchir, se prémunir aux évolutions qui vont arriver en lien avec l'intelligence artificielle.
Est-ce que demain, on va estimer qu'un algorithme peut prendre des décisions de justice ? Est-ce que demain, on aura un algorithme qui va décider qui pourra souscrire à telle ou telle assurance santé ?
C'est ça les questions qu'on va devoir se poser très, très, très rapidement. Après-demain, et là, je dirais en tout cas dans quelques années, on va avoir les voitures autonomes.
Probablement que le code de la route, on va pouvoir le reléguer dans les archives, puisque ce sont des algorithmes dans les voitures qui devront, qui pourront interagir entre eux.
Quelles sont les balises publiques, politiques qu'on va mettre ? Ces discussions-là, il faudrait en fait les avoir déjà aujourd'hui.
Oui. Revenons un petit peu sur la question de l'écologie qui est un sujet qui est abordé de manière un peu transversale tout le long de cette interview.
On a longtemps parlé d'une sortie du nucléaire en Belgique pour deux mille quinze. Finalement, ça a été retardé. Aujourd'hui, en deux mille dix-neuf, on n'y est toujours pas.
Est-ce que c'est en bonne voie aujourd'hui ? Est-ce qu'on est bientôt sortis du nucléaire en Belgique ?
Alors, ça fait longtemps que
ça devrait être effectivement le cas. Une loi a été votée sous l'impulsion des écologistes, notre première participation, enfin, notre unique jusqu'à présent au gouvernement fédéral,
suite aux élections de nonante-neuf, nonante-neuf, deux mille trois.
Donc, est-ce qu'on est en bonne voie ? Je pense qu'il y a un consensus politique aujourd'hui sur le fait de sortir du nucléaire, à part la N-VA.
Évidemment, c'est le plus grand parti aujourd'hui en Belgique. Mais à part la N-VA, je ne vois pas d'opposant politique majeur à la sortie du nucléaire.
La grande question, c'est comment et quand.
C'est ça, parce que ce n'est pas seulement une question politique, c'est aussi une question de savoir si on a, voilà, une solution en termes d'énergie renouvelable, etc.
Est-ce qu'on est en bonne voie au niveau pragmatique, j'ai envie de dire, au niveau logistique ?
Donc c'est tout à fait ça la question. Et la grande difficulté, c'est que tant qu'on n'a pas une date butoir précise et ferme, eh bien, il est difficile de mobiliser tous les acteurs pour investir dans les énergies renouvelables.
On en avait une pour deux mille quinze. Ça a été retardé de dix ans, il me semble.
Tout à fait.
Donc on en a une, deux mille vingt-cinq.
Voilà, il y en a une. Maintenant, il faut, il faut... Mais c'est ce que nous, comment dire, nous évertuons à dire, nous--
On s'époumone à le dire à la ministre Marghem, hein, mais il faut déclencher, je dirais, un plan d'investissement effectivement massif dans les énergies renouvelables et alternatives au nucléaire.
Par une phase de transition, évidemment, on ne fera pas ça du jour au lendemain. Mais je pense que l'enjeu, en fait, de la sortie nucléaire, il est là.
Il n'est plus tellement dans le fait de fixer une date, puisque si c'est pour fixer une date et tous les dix ans ou tous les cinq ans la repousser, ça n'a pas de sens.
Donc aujourd'hui, l'enjeu, c'est de mettre les moyens financiers pour faire cette transition énergétique. Je pense que c'est ça l'enjeu ici.
Donc aujourd'hui, non, on n'y est pas. Pour répondre clairement à votre question.
Mais par contre, la COP vingt-et-un, la COP vingt-trois qui vient de se terminer, tous ces accords internationaux qu'a signés la Belgique, elle nous oblige à le faire, en fait.
Enfin, elle nous oblige. Elle nous oblige à avoir des ambitions fortes en termes de diminution de gaz à effet de serre et en termes énergétiques.
Et donc, elle nous oblige à faire cette transition énergétique. Donc, quelque part, il est plus que temps d'agir si on veut remplir un jour nos obligations aussi internationales à ce niveau-là.
Mh. Bon, après toutes ces questions de politique politicienne, des institutions, des réformes, voilà, des élections, j'ai envie de revenir un petit peu, peut-être, à des questions un peu plus terre à terre.
On le disait, vous aviez dirigé un incubateur-
D'entreprises.
Greenbizz.
Greenbizz, tout à fait. Vous faites le constat, et vous êtes un des rares politiciens que j'ai trouvés à faire ce constat, vous faites le constat qu'en Belgique, le taux de création d'entreprises est ridiculement faible.
On était soit dernier en deux mille treize, soit avant-dernier, sachant que le dernier, c'est la Grèce.
Comment est-ce que vous expliquez en Belgique ce manque de culture entrepreneuriale, ce manque de création d'entreprise, tout simplement ?
Alors c'est vrai qu'au niveau européen, on est dans les derniers de classe, avant-dernier, comme vous l'avez dit.
Il y a juste la Grèce derrière nous. En taux vraiment de création d'entreprises. Je pense qu'il y a plusieurs facteurs.
La culture, oui, c'est vrai, on n'a pas vraiment une culture de-
Du risque.
En tout cas, qui encourage à se lancer, en fait. Je pense qu'on a,
certainement du côté francophone, bruxellois et wallon, il y a quand même-- il n'y a pas toujours eu une bonne presse ou une image très positive dans les médias, dans le grand public, de l'entrepreneuriat, du fait de prendre des risques.
C'était, voilà, c'était parfois vu de manière un peu biaisée, beaucoup de risques. Finalement, pourquoi ? Et pour quels résultats ?
Est-ce que ce n'est pas mieux dans d'autres, voilà, dans d'autres types de secteurs, de statuts, pour pouvoir avoir une vie décente et une qualité de vie telle que chacun a droit, évidemment.
Donc, je pense qu'il y a ce facteur-là. Je pense qu'il y a aussi le facteur d'exemplarité,
c'est-à-dire qu'on ne met pas assez, je trouve, en avant des entrepreneuses et des entrepreneurs dans les médias, dans les personnes qu'on souhaite récompenser au niveau de la société belge, je dirais.
Pas assez d'exemples à suivre.
Pas assez d'exemples. Il y en a plein, mais on ne les met pas en avant. Mais par contre, et c'est là où je veux quand même aussi inciter là-dessus, je pense que ça va mieux.
Je pense vraiment que ça va mieux. Certainement de nouveau dans les jeunes générations, mais je vois aussi les programmes dans les écoles, dans les universités.
Il y a de plus en plus de programmes pour créer son entreprise, pour essayer aussi d'arriver avec de nouvelles idées et de les transformer en entreprise ou en projet entrepreneurial.
Donc, je pense qu'effectivement, ça va mieux, mais il y a vraiment une barrière culturelle historique assez forte qui, je pense, est en train de bouger, mais ce n'est pas ça.
Et alors, il y a la barrière, par contre, pardon, par rapport au fait de se lancer. Il y a aussi la barrière par rapport au fait de grandir.
Moi, j'ai beaucoup rencontré d'entrepreneurs et de
responsables de PME dernièrement et beaucoup me disent qu'en Wallonie en particulier, mais je pense la même chose à Bruxelles, il y a vraiment ce côté, on a un peu peur de grandir, de devenir trop gros,
de se lancer dans d'autres pays, d'exporter.
Enfin, il y a vraiment un peu ce côté aussi du, je ne vais pas dire du confort d'être petit, mais de ne pas oser soi-même s'affirmer-
La fameuse, fameuse humilité à la belge quoi.
Peut-être, peut-être, mais je pense qu'il faut aussi essayer de sortir de cela en sachant que, de nouveau, et alors, troisième point, c'est il y a certaines barrières.
Je pense qu'aujourd'hui, pardon, il y a certaines barrières et je pense que, par exemple, aujourd'hui, pour vous lancer comme entrepreneur, si vous êtes salarié, eh bien, vous devez démissionner.
Et bon, on sait bien que si vous démissionnez, vous n'avez droit à aucune aide. Vous n'avez pas droit aux allocations de chômage, uniquement si vous êtes licencié.
Et donc, je pense qu'il y a quand même des choses à faire aussi. Et donc j'ai, par exemple, déposé une proposition de loi à ce sujet et donc qui permet de, en démissionnant, aussi avoir droit aux allocations de chômage.
Qui aura un autre nom, allocation de formation, mais ce serait le même type de montant et on pourrait accéder à ce système trois fois durant une carrière pour ne pas que ce soit non plus
un système de confort, mais plutôt un système de dire : j'ai envie de réorienter ma carrière professionnelle.
Et donc, je pense qu'il y a des choses à mettre en place, simplifier aussi la vie des entrepreneurs, que ce soit au niveau administratif.
En Belgique, je pense que l'administration n'est pas toujours très, comment dire, ne facilite pas vraiment la vie des entrepreneurs, des entrepreneuses qui se lancent.
Moi, je pense surtout aux petites structures, évidemment.
Oui, bien sûr.
Que ce soit l'administration fiscale, que ce soit l'administration sociale, tout est fait en fait pour, pour souvent-
Antidater.
Des grandes structures. Quand on se lance, ce n'est pas toujours le cas. Et donc, je pense qu'il y a quand même aussi une mentalité du côté de l'administration à faire bouger, qu'on soit effectivement plus agile, plus...
Et je ne suis pas convaincu qu'il faille les mêmes règles pour les entreprises du Bel 20 et celui ou celle qui se lance comme entrepreneur, comme indépendant.
Je pense qu'il y a aussi des réflexions à avoir de ce côté-là.
Oui, oui. Donc, il y a des gestes que le monde politique peut faire en termes d'infrastructures, en termes d'aides publiques, le chômage éventuellement.
Mais j'aimerais revenir sur cette barrière culturelle. Comment est-ce qu'on fait pour la briser, cette barrière culturelle aujourd'hui ?
Quels sont les gestes qu'on peut faire, qu'on peut prendre ?
Moi, je pense qu'il y a vraiment une valeur de, d'exemple, de montrer à quel point c'est, de mettre en avant au niveau des médias.
Par exemple, un sujet qui me tient aussi particulièrement à cœur, c'est l'entrepreneuriat féminin.
Bien sûr, oui.
Donc aujourd'hui, on sait qu'au niveau des indépendants en Belgique, on a un million cent mille indépendants, y compris indépendants complémentaires en Belgique, donc de personnes qui ont ce statut.
Et c'est, on est en plus ou moins un tiers de femmes et deux tiers, deux tiers d'hommes. Et cette proportion évolue en fait assez peu depuis les cinq à dix dernières années.
Et donc, de nouveau, moi, j'ai aussi discuté avec pas mal de femmes entrepreneuses, mais aussi de collectifs de femmes entrepreneuses qui essaient justement de mettre en avant.
Et souvent, ce qui revient en priorité, c'est oui, mais on montre très, très peu de femmes qui réussissent dans ce monde-là.
Et en fait, il y a très peu pour les petites filles ou pour les élèves ou pour les étudiantes. Il y a très peu de modèles, en fait.
Souvent, l'entrepreneur, c'est un mec qui se la raconte un peu, qui a réussi.
Steve Jobs Nation.
Voilà. L'image médiatique, je parle ici. Il y a des magazines, des magazines en lien avec ça ou à la télévision. Très peu de femmes.
Et donc pareil pour la diversité. Les entrepreneurs et sur la diversité, on en voit, alors, un, plus qu'avant, heureusement, mais c'est aussi très très peu.
Et donc, je pense qu'il y a toute une génération qui a du mal à s'identifier à ça et de dire : Finalement, c'est pour les autres.
Hein, dans le numérique. Si on revient deux secondes au numérique, très peu de nanas dans le numérique, très peu de femmes-
Très très peu.
Très très peu. Et, mais je pense qu'il y a aussi-- on s'imagine qu'informatique, ingénieur civil, que toutes ces études qui peuvent potentiellement mener à créer des algorithmes ou autres, c'est pour les mecs.
Et ça n'a aucun sens, évidemment. Mais dans l'inconscient collectif ou culturel, c'est très fort. Et ça, je pense qu'il y a vraiment des murs à briser.
C'est intéressant que vous évoquiez cette question puisque donc justement, en Belgique, le nombre de diplômés parmi tous les diplômés qui sont diplômés en ICT, donc dans les études numériques,
un point un pour cent, c'est le chiffre le plus faible de tous les pays de l'OCDE.
Et parmi les diplômés ICT, le nombre de femmes, c'est sept point deux pour cent, ce qui est également le score le plus faible de tous les pays de l'OCDE.
Donc, on a de sérieux travaux à faire ici en Belgique. On a fait plusieurs épisodes à ce sujet dans ce podcast, que ce soit avec Alexander De Croo, avec Interface 3, avec Molengeek.
Donc c'est un sujet que, voilà, qu'on connaît très bien, qui me fascine personnellement. Mais ce qui est intéressant, c'est que vous évoquez le manque d'exemples à suivre ou en tout cas, on ne les met pas assez en avant.
Mais le point de départ de cette question, c'était le fait qu'il y avait très peu d'entrepreneurs, trois point six pour cent, c'était en tout cas il y a quelques années.
Quand on part du constat, dire il y en a très peu, répondre, il faudrait plus mettre en avant ceux qu'on a. C'est un petit peu curieux.
Oui, mais je pense c'est une première étape pour donner envie en fait à ceux qui sont dans les écoles, aux jeunes de se lancer là-dedans.
Je pense qu'il y a effectivement cela, mais il y a aussi un autre point, c'est, mais je pense, c'est moins le cas qu'avant aussi, heureusement.
Donc les choses s'améliorent positivement. Mais je pense qu'historiquement, il y a eu aussi un peu une mauvaise image d'entrepreneur.
Hein, souvent, c'était le patron, quoi, le patron en costard avec son gros cigare et sa Jaguar. Enfin, je caricature complètement, hein.
Mais je pense que cette caricature-là, elle a vécu, elle a vécu longtemps dans l'imaginaire collectif aussi.
Et donc on se disait finalement : Ouais, être patron, est-ce que ce n'est pas finalement, entre guillemets, je ne vais pas dire sale, mais ce n'était pas en tout cas valorisé, quoi.
Est-ce que ça ne touche pas justement la question du rapport à l'argent ? On sait que, par exemple, en Wallonie, voilà, terre, je vais employer une expression un peu douteuse, mais terre socialiste depuis très longtemps.
Est-ce qu'il n'y a pas aussi une question de, voilà, la success story, l'argent, le succès ? Est-ce qu'on ne doit pas un petit peu redorer cette image-là ?
Oui, je pense. Je pense qu'il faut à la fois-- moi, c'est pour ça que je préfère aussi souvent parler d'émancipation, parce que je ne crois pas que tout le monde-
Certainement, ouais
...doit devenir entrepreneur. Je ne crois pas que les onze millions de Belges soient faits pour devenir entrepreneur ou entrepreneuse.
Je ne le pense pas. Par contre, le taux est très faible, donc il faut augmenter cette proportion, évidemment. Mais ce qu'il faut, c'est surtout que chacun et chacune puisse se dire : Je suis capable,
j'ai envie de faire telle ou telle chose, tel ou tel projet, qu'il soit culturel, qu'il soit économique, qu'il soit environnemental,
mais j'ai les capacités, j'ai envie, j'ai confiance en moi pour le faire.
Et ça, je pense que c'est important. Et pas rester dans des schémas où on se dit : Bah non, moi, je n'y arriverai pas. Ou, de schémas où on se dit : Non, finalement,
c'est trop risqué ou on ne le fait pas parce que finalement, l'image collective est négative, hein.
Je parlais de l'image du patron avec son gros cigare, sa Jaguar. Finalement, est-ce que c'est ça être entrepreneur aujourd'hui ?
Non, évidemment. Mais cette image-là existe encore, heureusement de moins en moins. Donc, je pense que c'est un ensemble de facteurs, évidemment.
Il n'y a pas qu'une seule cause. Ce serait trop facile, en fait, parce que-
Non, c'est sûr
...pour y remédier. Et donc, je pense qu'au niveau du rôle de l'État et de la politique, il faut surtout simplifier, parce que je pense que
l'argent, des subsides, il y en a déjà, ça existe, il y en a déjà, il y a déjà des montants considérables qui sont alloués pour aider les entreprises.
Donc moi, je suis plutôt partisan de plutôt concentrer ces moyens financiers plutôt que les augmenter considérablement.
Je pense qu'il y en a déjà beaucoup. Parfois, je pense que c'est un peu saupoudré, en fait. Et donc il faudrait davantage concentrer, ça, je pense, certainement vers tout ce qui est circulaire et durable, qui sont en plus des,
des secteurs créateurs d'emplois locaux.
Oui, tout à fait. Mais je pense que, donc au niveau subsides et moyens financiers, je pense qu'en grande partie, les choses sont faites.
Par contre, on pourrait les orienter différemment.
Donc, je crois que c'est vraiment plutôt sur les barrières administratives, la relation à l'administration, le fait que dès que vous vous inscrivez indépendant, vous devez déjà commencer à--
vous payez certaines cotisations avant même d'avoir commencé à facturer le premier euro de chiffre d'affaires.
Je crois que tout ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens, en fait, aujourd'hui. Et donc je crois que c'est-- je pense que c'est là que doit être la priorité de l'action politique, plutôt que de dire : On va mettre beaucoup plus d'argent pour
subsidier les entreprises.
Donc il faut continuer évidemment à soutenir les entreprises. Mais là, je ne pense pas qu'il faut spécialement augmenter les montants.
Par contre, en termes de simplification, en termes d'administration,
en termes de simplification des mécanismes de cotisations sociales, de statuts, je pense que là, il y a beaucoup de travail, surtout pour ceux et celles qui veulent se lancer.
On le disait, c'est un problème multifactoriel. Donc, il y a évidemment cette barrière culturelle très importante. Il y a également-- il y a également très certainement des,
des simplifications qui peuvent être faites au niveau administratif.
Deux freins que j'ai envie d'évoquer. Bon, c'est d'une part le, peut-être le manque de venture capital en Belgique, de voilà, de capitaux à risque.
Et également, un point que j'ai entendu dans votre programme, c'est-à-dire le fait de permettre aux entrepreneurs qui échouent d'éventuellement bénéficier d'aides.
Peut-être commencer sur ce point-là. Donc c'est un point que vous défendez comme quoi si on échoue dans, voilà, dans sa SPRL, dans son entreprise, en tant qu'indépendant, on pourrait alors bénéficier du chômage ?
Ou comment est-ce que ça fonctionnerait ?
Alors, ce ne sera pas exactement le chômage, mais effectivement, on estime qu'aujourd'hui, il ne faut pas punir ceux et celles qui osent se lancer, qui-- Et donc effectivement,
un mécanisme qui s'appelle le droit passerelle existe déjà,
mais il faut vraiment avoir fait faillite, avoir vraiment déposé le bilan au tribunal de commerce, ou avoir eu des circonstances tout à fait exceptionnelles de baisse de chiffre d'affaires.
Nous, en fait, on estime que toute personne qui déciderait, un peu dans la même logique de dire : « Je démissionne si je suis salarié pour me relancer et faire autre chose, j'ai quand même droit à une aide, à une allocation.
» On veut transposer ce principe au niveau des indépendants et de dire : « Ben si demain,
je me suis lancé comme un indépendant et finalement, ça ne me convient pas », pour toute raison que ce soit, on estime que si on arrête l'activité, on a aussi droit à ce droit passerelle.
Donc aujourd'hui, ce n'est pas le cas. Vous devez faire faillite. Nous, on estime qu'il faut élargir les conditions pour l'obtention de ce droit passerelle, c'est-à-dire avoir pendant un an un revenu de plus ou moins mille euros par mois, brut.
Donc, on n'est pas dans des conditions de nouveau de luxe ou de... On est vraiment dans des conditions de survie, de pouvoir vraiment continuer à vivre décemment, tout simplement.
Oui, on estime que c'est important.
Ce serait moins intimidant, oui.
Oui. Et donc ce serait-- C'est vraiment dans la même logique de dire : ne punissons pas,
celui ou celle qui souhaite entreprendre, qui souhaite se réorienter, en fait, que ce soit comme salarié, démissionner et faire autre chose, que ce soit comme indépendant, c'est-à-dire ce n'est pas pour moi, je me réoriente.
Je pense qu'il faut vraiment,
tout au long de la vie et des parcours professionnels,
que chacun puisse vraiment avoir droit à être soutenu, en fait, que ce soit en cas de maladie, mais ça, c'est le cas aujourd'hui, mais aussi en cas d'échec et en cas de réorganisation ou de relance professionnelle.
Oui. Donc, sur le deuxième aspect que j'évoquais, c'est-à-dire le paysage
des investisseurs belges. Bon, c'est très anecdotique puisque ça relève surtout de mon expérience personnelle, mais mon expérience, c'est que quand on voit un investisseur,
que ce soit en Wallonie ou à Bruxelles, c'est presque un rendez-vous chez le banquier.
On doit présenter ses chiffres et ainsi de suite. Et on a des réponses très frileuses, du style à Meusinvest, par exemple, donc, où travaille Jean-Michel Javaux, il me semble,
des réponses du style : « Tiens, mais ta start-up n'est pas rentable dans dix-huit mois après sa création.
Mais qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ? Non,
non, merci ». Et va vraiment systématiquement, chez toute une série de groupes, j'ai vu vraiment ce besoin systématique de récupérer ses sous très rapidement après et de ne pas finalement les investir
comme le ferait un capitaux de risque pour peut-être les perdre.
Quand on est, voilà, dans ce paysage belge-là, est-ce que ça a vraiment du sens pour les,
les institutions belges de tout faire pour garder nos entreprises et les ancrer, voilà, en Wallonie ou à Bruxelles,
si c'est pour les défavoriser fortement à l'échelle internationale, puisque, voilà, on peut moins facilement lever des fonds
aujourd'hui avec le Brexit ou que ce soit aux États-Unis ou ainsi de suite ?
Parce que, bon, je sais que c'est une question très pointue et très difficile, mais je sais pas si vous avez réponse à ce sujet-là.
Non, je pense c'est une question importante. Moi, je vois deux éléments. Le premier, c'est au niveau des capitaux.
On sait bien que c'est un des, vraiment des freins pour se lancer. C'est effectivement les fonds propres. Je ne sais pas si systématiquement l'État doit être là pour
prendre du risque et se substituer finalement à l'actionnaire potentiel.
Dans le constat où il n'y a pas beaucoup de venture capital
en Belgique, c'est peut-être dans ce scénario-là que, voilà, les institutions comme le Wing, par exemple, se positionnent en disant : « Bon, on va prendre le risque à leur place » puisqu'ils ne sont pas là.
Mais donc, je pense que de manière générale, c'est une réflexion en tout cas à avoir. Moi, je pense, mais donc je veux aussi en arriver en disant, je pense que dans certains secteurs,
et dans certaines conditions, ça doit être le cas.
Et donc, je préfère que des structures comme Meusinvest, comme Finance Brussels, SRIB à Bruxelles, comme d'autres invest public,
prennent en fait des prises de participation dans des capitaux de PME ou de start-up, plutôt qu'effectivement,
financer via des subsides ou le retour sur finalement l'intérêt général et le retour par rapport au public n'est pas toujours évident.
Il y a parfois des entreprises qui sont subsidiées pendant des années et des années. On se demande finalement s'il y a encore un... quel est l'objectif.
Moi, je préfère que l'État prenne une prise de participation. Comme ça, au moins, les dividendes aussi bien financiers, mais aussi bien en termes d'emplois locaux ancrés chez nous, en Wallonie, à Bruxelles, eh bien, on peut avoir une,
une vue par rapport à cela.
On voit bien ce qui est arrivé au niveau de groupes. Là, c'est plus des PME, mais c'est parce que c'est des angles qui ont marqué, mais c'est au niveau d'ArcelorMittal, au niveau d'autres qui ont reçu des subsides,
qui ont reçu des millions de subsides de la Région wallonne en particulier.
Mais à Bruxelles, on a fait la même chose avec d'autres entreprises.
Et finalement, le jour où l'actionnaire à l'autre bout du monde décide de fermer et de mettre sur le carreau des milliers de familles, et donc de travailleurs, on ne sait rien faire.
Donc, je préfère effectivement que l'État ait une prise de participation dans le capital pour pouvoir au moins avoir une vue sur ces décisions.
Et généralement, c'est plutôt des participations minoritaires. Et donc, je pense que ça doit vraiment... Par contre, ça doit être fait dans des secteurs stratégiques où on estime qu'il y a un retour
pour, je dirais, l'intérêt général, la société, que ce soit en termes d'emploi, en termes de secteur.
Je pense que le secteur numérique, le secteur environnemental, il y a des secteurs aujourd'hui dans lesquels il faut investir.
Sinon, on va rester, je dirais, à côté du train qui passe. Par contre, je pense que ça doit être fait de... ça doit pas être une systématique.
C'est ça que je voulais dire. Mais qu'on puisse créer des structures. Vous savez, moi, j'avais regardé une étude en Flandre.
Le premier investisseur dans tout ce qui est start-up digitale en Flandre, c'est PMV. Donc c'est l'équivalent de Sogepa, donc ce qui est vraiment la structure d'investissement public.
Et donc c'est PMV. Donc c'est vraiment la structure du gouvernement flamand. Et donc c'est le premier investisseur aujourd'hui dans les start-up digitales flamandes.
Donc, et donc, c'est évidemment pas assez. Mais donc ça veut dire que, enfin, quelque part, je dis ça en...
en pointant du doigt le fait qu'on manque évidemment de structures de financement et que souvent, les start-up, en tout cas digitales, doivent aller dans d'autres pays, essentiellement anglo-saxons,
pour trouver des financements.
Donc c'est vrai que c'est un problème. De nouveau, comment valoriser au mieux nos compétences, nos régions pour attirer des investisseurs ?
C'est aussi une vraie question. Est-ce que, voilà, est-ce que Bruxelles ne pourrait pas aussi devenir une capitale digitale inclusive ?
Parce que je pense que c'est aussi un défi. C'est aussi des questions, je pense qu'il faudra à un moment mettre sur la table.
Dans le constat où on disait le taux de création d'entreprise est très faible, le pourcentage d'étudiants en informatique est très très faible.
Quand on pose tous ces constats-là, c'est difficile de placer Bruxelles ou la Belgique comme, voilà, comme fer de lance de cette révolution start-up nation, etc.
Oui, en même temps, je pense pas qu'on, enfin que start-up nation doit être l'alpha et l'oméga de l'objectif politique.
Moi, je pense que ce qui est important, c'est qu'on ne reste pas... Non, mais moi, je crois beaucoup dans la transition numérique.
Je pense qu'elle peut... c'est une énorme opportunité, que ce soit en termes de création d'emplois, que ce soit en termes environnemental, mais il faut que nous-mêmes, nous décidions ce qu'on en fait.
Ça doit pas être fait du numérique pour du numérique, ça doit être inclusif. On peut pas laisser la moitié de la population de côté, ce qui serait le, enfin, ce qui est souvent le cas aujourd'hui.
Souvent, c'est des personnes qui effectivement, qui ont eu accès à des études, qui sont diplômées, qui...
Une start-up sur deux, une start-up sur deux ou presque en Wallonie vient du Brabant wallon.
Voilà, par exemple. Donc, c'est clair. Donc, il faut que le numérique soit inclusif et crée de l'emploi de qualité.
Si c'est pour créer une start-up qui, dans cinq ans, est rachetée par Google et qui déménage en Californie, je pense qu'on est tous perdants, en tout cas au niveau de la société belge, au niveau de l'État belge. Sauf, pardon.
Sauf le fondateur.
Voilà, sauf le fondateur, effectivement.
Ou la fondatrice.
Mais donc,
je pense qu'il y a effectivement,
des choses à faire par rapport à cela, mais il faut vraiment, voilà, à la fois investir dans le digital et la transition numérique, mais surtout, au niveau politique, je pense avoir une vision de qu'est-ce qu'on a envie de,
de faire avec le numérique, en termes d'opportunités, d'emplois, d'inclusion, et moi, je rajoute systématiquement l'environnement parce qu'on en parle trop peu.
Mais le numérique a aussi une influence décisive sur l'environnement. Alors, on parle souvent des consommations énergétiques via les applications, etc.
Mais il n'y a pas que ça. Il y a aussi les ressources qui sont consommées avec le numérique, les terres rares, ces autres enjeux-là.
Il va falloir aussi penser à une transition numérique durable. Ça veut dire penser aussi en termes de serveurs, en termes de matériel, en termes de recyclage, comment ne pas faire exploser
l'exploitation des ressources mondiales par rapport à cela.
Yes. Autre dossier que vous suivez de près, ce sont les infrastructures publiques. Alexander De Croo a annoncé il y a quelques mois l'arrivée d'un nouvel opérateur, un quatrième opérateur GSM.
J'ai l'impression que dans l'opposition, on est très froid face à cette idée. On... qu'est-ce que... comment se place Ecolo par rapport à ça ?
Alors, c'est un débat, je dirais, comme souvent, qui a plusieurs facettes. Je pense que c'est difficile de dire on est pour ou contre de manière brute.
Je pense qu'ici, il y a vraiment deux aspects spécifiques, et en particulier sur le marché belge et télécom.
Donc c'est par rapport à l'appel d'offre pour la 5G, hein, où il veut effectivement qu'un opérateur supplémentaire puisse rentrer sa candidature.
On parle beaucoup de Free Mobile.
Oui.
C'est le nom qui se met au mur.
Mais je pense qu'il y a deux choses. Pour le consommateur, et c'est langue d'attaque souvent de... Enfin, ça a toujours été pour moi langue d'attaque de Alexander De Croo, c'est de dire : Pour le consommateur, ce sera positif.
C'est vrai qu'on paye cher en Belgique.
Parce que effectivement, on paye cher en Belgique et donc ça pourrait diminuer les prix. Donc moi, de ce point de vue là, j'ai aucun problème parce que cela favorise et donne un accès plus grand d'ailleurs à tous les consommateurs.
Donc ça, c'est la première chose. Le deuxième élément qui doit arriver dans la réflexion, c'est au niveau justement de l'investissement dans l'infrastructure.
On sait bien qu'aujourd'hui, Proximus, qui est un autre opérateur télécom public, encore aujourd'hui, cinquante-trois pour cent de Proximus appartient à l'État belge, donc à vous, à vous et à moi.
Et eux investissent massivement dans tout ce qui est fibre pour justement la transition numérique.
Et donc Proximus, chaque fois, brandit l'argument de dire : « Si nous, on ne s'y retrouve pas en termes de rentabilité, on ne pourra plus investir comme ça.
» Donc, moi, je trouve que ça sonne un peu comme du chantage qui est assez malsain. Mais il faut, voilà, prendre cela en compte aussi.
Et enfin, et enfin, évidemment, mais ça, ça nous est aussi cher en tant qu'écologiste, c'est l'impact de la 5G et de potentiellement l'installation généralisée de nouvelles antennes sur la santé, en fait.
Et donc, je pense qu'il va falloir aussi...
Alors là, le fait d'amener un opérateur supplémentaire, sans doute, ne changera pas grand-chose, mais par rapport à ce débat sur la 5G, je pense qu'il faut aussi se poser des questions en termes de santé publique.
Je pense pas qu'il faut être s'opposer à la 5G, ça, en tant que tel, mais il faut pouvoir mener de nouveau une analyse profonde par rapport à cela, notamment sur la multiplication des antennes.
Donc voilà, vous dire oui ou non, voilà, sur ce débat-là, on n'a pas mené d'opposition frontale, effectivement, parce qu'on estime qu'il y a plusieurs facteurs en jeu.
L'IBPT a remis une étude qui est aussi plutôt, je dirais, contrastée, mais alors certains vont dire que l'IBPT est influencé.
Donc moi, je préfère voir comment ce dossier va évoluer. Mais à ce stade, ce qui est important, c'est que,
c'est évidemment les consommateurs, qu'est-ce qui va en advenir pour les consommateurs et aussi pour l'infrastructure publique en lien avec les télécoms.
On sent, voilà, on sent plusieurs nuances par rapport à la position d'Alexander De Croo, qui est donc le ministre tutelle des infrastructures publiques, bpost, les télécoms, etc.
À l'époque, plus aujourd'hui. Voilà, vous êtes évidemment médiatiquement très fort en opposition avec ce que proposait le ministre Marghem.
Voilà, c'est déjà plus nuancé, plus subtil pour ce qui est du travail d'Alexander De Croo. Est-ce que vous estimez que vous auriez pu...
Est-ce que, est-ce que dans un gouvernement, disons, en 2019, où Alexander De Croo revient comme ministre de bpost et des télécoms, est-ce que vous estimez que vous seriez compatible ?
Disons qu'humainement, il y a pas de problème. Moi, je fais pas d'exclusives par rapport aux uns et aux autres humainement.
Il est sympa.
Mais je pense que par rapport à bpost, par exemple, moi, je pense qu'il a eu un... Il y a deux grandes difficultés par rapport à la politique et sa vision politique sur bpost.
C'est de un, par rapport aux conflits sociaux qu'il y a eus et qui ont été très importants, notamment durant le mois de novembre.
On n'avait plus connu ça chez bpost depuis vingt ans, hein. Donc c'est pas... Et bpost, sincèrement, c'est pas la culture du tout de la grève où on en a quatre, cinq par an.
Pas du tout. C'est une entreprise qui,
historiquement, a eu toujours un,
un modèle social plutôt apaisé, bon, avec des hauts et des bas, bien entendu, des résultats positifs, même si la bourse, si le cours a chuté en bourse, mais ça, ce sont les aléas de l'économie, je dirais, à très court terme.
Oui, puis c'est aussi symptomatique des temps, de l'époque actuelle où la poste est forcément moins utilisée, moins utile qu'auparavant.
Et donc, donc moi, je trouve qu'il y a eu trop peu d'attention par rapport au climat social à bpost. Parce qu'il a dit toujours : moi, voilà, je suis ministre libéral et donc je ne me mets pas,
dans la gestion de l'entreprise publique.
Alors moi, je dis, moi, je suis d'accord sur le fait qu'un ministre ne doit pas être le CEO d'une entreprise, totalement d'accord là-dessus.
C'est pas lui qui doit être quotidiennement à la manœuvre, pas du tout. Par contre,
quand même, aller autour de la table des négociations, forcer les partenaires, directions, syndicats, à être autour de la table pour reprendre le dialogue social, ça, ça me paraît être son rôle.
Je pense qu'il ne l'a pas fait ou trop tard. Donc ça, c'est premier point. Deuxième point, sa volonté de vendre. Clairement, il l'a dit, c'est-à-dire passer en dessous de cinquante pour cent.
Moi, sincèrement, pour toutes les raisons que je viens d'expliquer, je pense, ça reste un service public, en fait. Et un service public doit rester, par définition, public.
Et donc, la grande difficulté qu'on aurait avec lui, c'est ça, c'est qu'il veut vendre bpost. Nous, c'est pas du tout une option.
Donc travailler avec lui dans tout ce qui est agenda digital, sincèrement, on a peu de grandes, de grandes divergences.
Sauf que nous, on aimerait un peu plus inclusif et une touche environnementale quand même plus forte. Sur bpost, il faudrait vraiment qu'il revienne sur ces considérations de privatisation.
Très bien. Un dernier mot alors sur, ben vous le disiez, vous faisiez partie de la commission d'enquête autour des attentats du vingt-deux mars 2016.
Question peut-être un peu vague, mais je me souviens qu'au lendemain de ces attentats, on entendait des hommes politiques, que ce soit en Belgique ou en France, faire le constat de dire : Mais c'est tragique, mais il faut s'y attendre.
Ce sera de plus en plus récurrent. Ça n'est presque plus surprenant. Est-ce que, est-ce qu'on vit aujourd'hui dans ce monde-là, de ce monde où peut-être que demain, il y aura une autre attaque terroriste ?
Moi, j'ai pas envie d'être alarmiste à ce point-là. Ce qui est certain, c'est que le risque zéro n'existe pas. Il faut jamais se reposer totalement sur laurier en se disant : C'est bon, c'est passé, ça n'arrivera plus.
Donc, je pense qu'il faut toujours rester préparé. Il faut avoir un appareil d'État, sécurité intérieure, justice, qui fonctionne...
Oui.
...dans lequel on investit, ce qui n'avait pas été le cas. Et je pense que ce qui s'est aussi passé, en particulier en Belgique, je parle surtout sur la comparaison par rapport à la France...
Bien sûr.
...c'est que je ne crois pas que la Belgique était prête...
D'accord.
...à affronter des attentats terroristes, des attentats terroristes tout court, et en plus de l'ampleur que ceux qu'on a eus à Zaventem et à Maelbeek.
On n'était pas prêts, tout simplement. Alors, évidemment, on n'est jamais prêts, mais on a vraiment eu, que ce soit au niveau de nos services de renseignement, qui n'étaient au courant de rien ou presque,
au niveau de notre infrastructure de sécurité intérieure, d'accompagnement des victimes aussi.
On n'était pas du tout, encore aujourd'hui, malheureusement, organisés, préparés au niveau de l'État pour accompagner ce type de drame et accompagner les victimes.
Donc vraiment, là, je pense qu'on est passés au niveau de la Belgique et de la culture, mais là même la culture au niveau du fonctionnement de notre État.
On est passés effectivement dans un autre monde où la menace terroriste est très forte. Depuis lors, elle a diminué, tant mieux, mais de nouveau, le risque zéro n'existe pas.
Il faut pas se reposer sur laurier, mais je pense qu'effectivement, il y a eu un grand changement de culture au sein de nos services, ce qui est positif,
mais, que ce soit en termes d'échange d'informations, que ce soit en termes de fonctionnement, qui était beaucoup trop en silo, hein, chacun dans son coin...
Ouais.
...sans se partager l'information. Je pense que vraiment, on était pas prêts et qu'aujourd'hui, tout ça,
mais notamment grâce au rapport qui a été voté à l'unanimité, donc parfois, les partis peuvent arriver à des accords globaux et larges, et tant mieux, on a pu vraiment réformer en profondeur et changer la culture.
Mais ça va prendre du temps. C'est pas du jour au lendemain. Donc restons attentifs, mais ne versons pas dans la panique et dans la panique générale.
C'est ça. Donc des réformes importantes au niveau
sécuritaire, au niveau de la réponse de la menace terroriste. Ce qui concerne le travail en amont, est-ce que vous estimez qu'on a eu des évolutions satisfaisantes à ce niveau-là pour, voilà, pour
empêcher la radicalisation dans les communes de Bruxelles ?
Alors, là, je pense qu'effectivement, ça a été la grande, le grand absent de ces discussions. D'ailleurs, on l'a souvent dénoncé.
C'est qu'au niveau, en tout cas, de la politique du gouvernement, il y a beaucoup de réponses sécuritaires qui, parfois, pour nous, allaient trop loin, notamment en termes de libertés individuelles.
Mais on a très peu, on a fait très peu pour tout ce qui était prévention. Et donc nous, notre
ligne d'argumentation était toujours de dire chaque euro qu'on a investi dans la sécurité, et il faut le faire, il faut renforcer nos services, on a désinvesti nos services, il faut investir dans la sécurité.
On a dit quatre cent millions, hein, à l'époque, les fameux quatre cent millions qu'on a investis en plus dans la sécurité, il faut le faire.
Il faut engager des policiers de quartier, il faut renforcer certaines structures, mais il faut aussi investir les mêmes quatre cent millions dans la formation, l'enseignement, la culture.
Parce que c'est comme ça qu'on va battre l'obscurantisme et le discours de haine de Daesh. Parce que c'est de ça qu'on parle.
Et donc là, je pense qu'effectivement, les moyens n'ont pas été mis. On a mis les moyens dans la sécurité,
on a, alors oublié, alors est-ce que c'était fait exprès ou pas, je ne sais pas, mais ce qui est certain, c'est que ces mêmes moyens n'ont pas été mis dans tout ce qui est prévention, formation, politique culturelle.
Et ça, c'est effectivement quelque chose qu'il faut faire de manière urgente, parce que ce qui se passe dans les quartiers, à Bruxelles, à Anvers, dans d'autres grandes villes, c'est lié à ça.
C'est qu'il y a toute une jeunesse aujourd'hui qui est privée de repères et qui ne voit pas, justement, comment s'émanciper dans un projet quel qu'il soit.
Donc ça, c'est vraiment l'enjeu, ouais.
On en revient donc au constat de la lasagne à la belge, où finalement, ces compétences de culture, d'enseignement, etc., ne sont pas des compétences fédérales.
Donc, on a le fédéral qui peut travailler à la réparation, à la protection, à la sûreté, mais pas tellement en amont, pas tellement en prévention.
C'est vrai,
mais j'ai envie de dire aussi, il faut un peu de volontarisme politique. Je veux dire, à un moment donné, l'ex-ministre de l'Intérieur, Jan Jambon,
a commencé à mettre des moyens dans certains services qui étaient au-delà de sa compétence,
que ce soit en termes de prévention, que ce soit en termes de lutte contre le radicalisme.
Donc, voilà, à un moment donné, il y a moyen de faire des choses.
Il a fait un peu, pas assez.
Voilà, bien sûr. Mais donc, il y a moyen de faire des choses. Donc, je pense qu'à un moment donné, quand il y a une forte volonté politique, ben, les institutions, elles doivent suivre.
Moi, je ne suis pas de ceux qui se cachent derrière la lasagne belge, même si elle existe et que je la regrette et que j'aimerais bien simplifier de manière assez drastique, d'ailleurs,
mais je n'ai pas envie de me cacher derrière ça pour justifier l'inaction.
Très bien. Gilles Vanden Burre, on a largement dépassé les septante minutes. Merci beaucoup pour, voilà, pour ces cent-cinq minutes passées ensemble.
Chers auditeurs, à dans deux semaines. Et Gilles Vanden Burre, au revoir.
Merci, au revoir.
Et voilà, c'est déjà tout pour ces Septante Minutes avec Gilles Vanden Burre. Et même un peu plus, puisque on va pas se mentir, on a largement dépassé.
Ce sera le dernier épisode Accès politique avant un bon moment. Sans doute qu'il y aura des choses à dire après le vingt-six mai, le jour des élections.
On verra à ce moment-là comment gérer ça. Une chose est sûre, le prochain mois s'annonce intense.
Je le disais sur Twitter, dans les semaines qui viennent, je vais passer Septante Minutes avec, par exemple, Myriam Leroy de la RTBF, avec Thierry Geerts, le CEO de Google Belgique.
Donc de très bons épisodes en perspective. Si vous avez des questions pour elle ou pour lui, si vous avez des suggestions d'invités, si vous avez un feedback sur cet épisode, n'hésitez pas à prendre contact avec moi.
Ça fait toujours plaisir. Pour ne rien rater, je vous invite à suivre Septante Minutes sur les réseaux sociaux. Il y a des liens dans la description.
Et surtout, à vous abonner au podcast sur votre plateforme de podcast préférée, que ce soit iTunes, Spotify, Pocket Cast ou tout ce que vous voulez.
C'est gratuit, c'est chouette et ça rend plus beau. Voilà, c'est tout pour moi. Merci d'avoir écouté et à dans deux semaines. Bye bye.